Fritz.
Letzter Donnerstag am Monat. Der gewohnte Sound aus den Fritzradios stürmt das ganz besondere Blumens, das Chaosradio, das heute ein großes Jubiläum feiert, nämlich Folge 163. Wir haben überlegt zu diesem Anlass, von den vergangenen Chaosradio-Folgen die ersten zwei Minuten einfach aneinanderzuschneiden und zu lupen, aber haben uns dann doch dagegen entschieden. Stattdessen sind heute Tim Pritloff und Pawel Mayer im Studio zu Gast. Hallo und guten Abend. Jetzt doch keine Lubs? Ne, wir haben gedacht, ihr redet ein bisschen, also ein kleines bisschen.
Wir sollen auch unsere Amnesie mit ausgleichen.
Wir spielen auch ganz, ganz, ganz viel Musik, aber so ein kleines bisschen könntet ihr vielleicht.
Ich dachte, wir machen jetzt Chaosradio wie früher.
Was heißt denn wie früher?
Na, alle reden die ganze Zeit durcheinander und sind total bekippt.
Entschuldigung, ihr seid zu zweit hier. Wie wollt ihr denn alle durcheinander reden?
Das kriegt ihr das gehen. Kein Problem. Überhaupt kein Problem.
Na, könnt ihr gleich mal anfangen. 163 ist jetzt nicht wirklich das Jubiläum, sondern?
15 Jahre Chaosradio.
Ist einer von euch da schon dabei gewesen? Bei der ersten Sendung?
Ja.
Wie war das? Was wir neulich überlegt hatten, wer hatte überhaupt die Idee?
Die Idee war, also es gab damals eine Häufung, wie soll man das erklären? Also viele, die damals Club waren, waren auch in einer Firma, die damals mit Fritz zusammen so ein lustiges Projekt gemacht hat, so ein Telefonspiel, so ein Telefonlabyrinth. Das lief so 95. Und damals war Johnny Häusler ja hier Moderator und darüber gab es dann sozusagen die ersten kulturellen Beziehungen. Und da entstand so die Idee, Mensch, wie wär's denn mal, wenn der CCC da mal eine Sendung machen würde. Und das fand dann recht schnell anklang. Und dann wurde irgendwann eben der November 95 als Startdatum ausgerufen. Und ja, da waren wir dann zu viert am Start. Also genau genommen zu fünft. Also Johnny war damals halt Moderator. Und neben mir waren Andi, Steini und Frank dabei.
Und das war tatsächlich aber sozusagen gleich und sofort die erste Sendung Chaosradio. Oder war es eher so, ja, lass mal eine Sendung machen und gucken wir mal. Und dann wird es vielleicht...
Nee, das war dann schon gleich von vornherein so gedacht, dass das einmal im Monat stattfindet. Wobei wir im November gestartet sind und gleich im Dezember aussetzen mussten. Wir würden das ja immer machen. Wegen des Kongresses. Aber das war kein Problem. Das Thema war halt, der CCC stellt sich vor, leider gibt es von diesen ersten zehn Sendungen keine Aufzeichnungen mehr. Das haben wir damals irgendwie verkackt, weil wir irgendwie, glaube ich, noch überhaupt nicht so auf den Zeiger hatten, dass das ein Projekt wird, was mal 15 Jahre lang...
Ja, die Aufzeichnung, jetzt müsste natürlich wieder der typische Höreraufruf kommen, falls jemand noch die...
Ja, warte, wir haben da mal was vorbereitet. Jetzt anrufen.
0331 70 97 110.
Also wer noch eine von den ersten zehn Sendungen am Start hat, bitte jetzt anrufen.
Ja, also wer wirklich irgendwelche Tapes hat, unter Umständen die ersten zehn Sendungen. Ich meine, ich hab da die Hoffnung eigentlich schon lange aufgegeben. Es gibt einen, den ich kenne, der meint, er hätte da noch Tapes irgendwo ganz unten in dieser Kiste, die er schon immer mal ausräumen wollte. Dazu ist er leider noch nicht gekommen. Ja, Draga, du weißt, du bist gemeint. Grab mal. Aber ja, bisher kam da nichts. Alles, was wir haben, also auch so die, von denen wir Aufzeichnung haben, die sind auch unvollständig teilweise. Es gibt da so ein paar Sendungen, die sind so ein bisschen durcheinander, wo wir nicht so ganz so sicher sind, ob das wirklich alles eine Sendung ist, die da in dem Fall gelandet ist. Eine der besten Sendungen, die, wie ich finde, wer den noch nicht gehört, der hat Chaosradio 23, ist leider auch nur zwei von den drei Stunden übrig geblieben.
Ich habe auch gehört, dass es keinen Unterschied gemacht hat. Es ist immer ein Problem, muss man sagen, einfach, dass noch mal anfangen kann und das schließt sich dann auch.
Ja, die 23, da ist es eigentlich egal. Trotzdem sollte irgendjemand davon eine vollständige Aufzeichnung haben. Also das, da wäre ich ewig dankbar.
Nach einer geilen Verschwörungsjugend, die fehlende Stunde von 23. Da, wo wir die wirklich schwitzeren Sachen gesagt haben. Auf der Website steht jetzt nicht irgendwie 50 Jahre Chaosradio, wir suchen alte Aufzeichnung, sondern da steht Kulturtechnik, Technik Kultur.
Genau.
Was hat es miteinander zu tun?
Ja, das wollen wir unter anderem mal hier ergründen. Also es war natürlich schon so ein bisschen auch die Überlegung, okay, jetzt haben wir hier 15 Jahre Chaosradio und jetzt hier einfach nur so eine Jubelsendung zu machen mit, ha früher war alles besser oder auch nicht. Das reicht nicht. Trotzdem wollten wir auch so ein bisschen irgendwas finden, wo man auch mal ein wenig zurückblickt. Weil wenn man sich das mal anschaut, was vor 15 Jahren alles so losging. Also ich war gerade in den letzten Tagen am laufenden Meter auf irgendwelchen 15-Jahre-Partys. Die Seabase ist vor 15 Jahren gegründet worden. Auch der Chaos Computer Club Berlin selbst ist als Verein vor 15 Jahren gestartet.
Wenn man die Berichte von der Party ernsthaft glaubt, wundere ich mich, dass du heute schon hier sein kannst.
Und lang. Und jetzt bin ich ein bisschen aus der Spur. Genau, das Thema. Kulturtechnik. Genau. Und wo wir so ein bisschen drüber nachgedacht haben, ist, dass wir ja eigentlich seit 95, als das ja auch mit dem Internet losging und wo wir ja in dieser etwas besonderen Rolle waren damals, dass auch schon so zu 100 Prozent auf so einer täglichen Basis zu leben, wie das für viele vielleicht heute erst der Fall ist. Für manche auch immer noch nicht. Aber viele leben heute halt auch so ein 24 Stunden Internetding. Und das ist irgendwie auch normal, ohne dass man da sich jetzt so besonders reinstürzt oder gleich als der Übergeek gilt. Ja, mit Facebook arbeiten, mit E-Mail arbeiten, mit Mobiltelefonie, also generell mit Technik permanent irgendwie online zu sein oder zumindest zu kommunizieren oder sie in anderer Form für sich urbar zu machen. Das sind mittlerweile erlernte Dinge. Und wir hatten halt damals so das Privileg, viele Ressourcen im Zugriff zu haben, früh so 24 Stunden Internet zu haben, sodass wir eben viele Dinge auch schon so ein bisschen vorweg leben konnten. Und das haben wir ja auch versucht, in Chaosradio mit einzubringen. Und eigentlich haben wir ja immer so ein bisschen von der Zukunft berichtet, immer so Themen gemacht, die eigentlich...
Ja, und festgestellt, dass wir unglaublich oft daneben lagen.
Okay, geilste Vorhersage, die nicht geklappt hat?
Ja, ich hab das jetzt nicht alles durchgehört. Ich weiß nicht, Pavel, hast du jetzt gerade irgendwas im Sinn?
Beziehungsweise, naja, wir hatten vorhin ja das Thema, aber ich...
Ja, Multicast im Internet ist mal groß gepriesen worden. Das wird alles revolutionieren. Davon ist heute nichts zu sehen.
Entschuldigung, was bitte?
Also, was weiß ich, wenn man heute so über Streaming nachdenkt, wie diese Sendung jetzt selbstverständlich gestreamt wird. Also es war ja am Anfang ein langer Kampf, überhaupt erst mal einen Stream zu haben. Beziehungsweise überhaupt erst mal eine Aufzeichnung zu haben. Aber irgendwann hat das dann hier auch Einzug gehalten, hat dann aber auch lang gedauert, bis es hier mal serienmäßig in B3 Streams gab.
Wir hatten jahrelang einen ganz tollen Weirdstream.
Jaja, reden wir nicht drüber. Sonst muss ich auch noch über diese Flash-Seite.
Ja, falls sie mich hier rausdrehen. Ich meine, die sind so zweit. Ich bin alleine.
Ich finde unsere neue Internetseite trotzdem toll.
Ja, also keine Ahnung. Ich meine, das könnt ihr uns natürlich auch mal erzählen, wo wir unter Umständen total daneben gelegen haben oder wo wir eben auch richtig gelegen haben. Ja, und jetzt noch mal so mit der Kulturtechnik. Also eine Kulturtechnik ist ja etwas, was sich die Gesellschaft als so kollektive Gabe aneignet und dann zum Einsatz bringt und die dann in der Folge üblicherweise auch den Fortschritt der Gesellschaft befördert oder vielleicht auch markiert. Das sind so Sachen wie Feuermachen zum Beispiel. Das ist so eine Kulturtechnik der ersten Zeit. Und das hat natürlich nachhaltig die Dinge in Wallung gebracht. Ja, Menschen waren in der Lage, Fleisch zu garen und damit mehr Fleisch auch zu essen. Und das hat die Hirne wachsen lassen. Ja, mittlerweile geht das hier in eine andere Richtung. Aber nichtsdestotrotz, das sind eben solche Kulturtechniken. Und wir haben halt auch das Wort dann einfach mal umgedreht und wollen auch über Technikkultur reden. Weil das ist glaube ich das, was wir immer so ein bisschen gelebt haben. Wir waren eingebettet in Technik. Das war ja jetzt nicht nur Internet, das war auch Mobilfunk. Am Anfang 1995, da ging das so mit SMS und D-Netz überhaupt erst so richtig los. Pavel, weißt du noch weitere Beispiele aus dem Kopf? Also auch das ganze Aufkommen von Kameras, von digitaler Fotografie. Das sind ja alles Sachen, die vor 15 Jahren überhaupt nicht normal waren. Und das haben wir mittlerweile einfach dann uns einverleibt.
Ja, ich kann mich an Hans erste MP3-Sammlung erinnern, die da auf dem Server zum Beispiel stand. Und das war so in der Zeit. Da kann ich mich ganz gut dran erinnern. Da war maximal 64 Kilobit ISDN noch angesagt. Und da kam Hans und sagte, boah, es gibt hier jetzt so eine Möglichkeit, Musikstücke zu komprimieren. Die brauchen dann nur ganz wenig Platz. Und dann kann man sich die sogar über eine 64 Kilobit-Leitung Musik ziehen. Und das war zum Beispiel so ein Moment, an dem ich mich erinnere, weil es gab eine Zeit, da war der Begriff MP3 einfach unbekannt. Und das war der Zeitpunkt, wo ich das erste Mal von MP3 gehört habe.
Ist Filesharing eine Kulturtechnik, die sich quasi in den letzten Jahren entwickelt hat?
Auf jeden Fall. Also das denke ich, das ist sogar eine ganz wichtige Kulturtechnik, die sich entwickelt hat, dass man einfach das Wissen darum erworben hat, wie man eben schnell solche Dateien, wie sagt man so schön, teilen kann. Ich finde das Wort furchtbar. Sharing ist auch grauenhaft.
Ich meine, das Internet ist eine Kopiermaschine. Die ganzen Digitalrechner sind Kopiermaschinen. Die tun eigentlich in einer Natur nichts anderes als kopieren. Und wenn man eine lange Leitung dazwischen hat, ist es natürlich völlig naheliegend. Aber ich kenne es eigentlich gar nicht anders. Auch von Kassetten, Floppy, Disketten, Festplatten, Zeiten. Also wie gesagt, es geht gar nicht anders. Man muss im Gegenteil riesige Klimmzüge machen, um das zu erschweren oder zu verhindern. Und insofern würde ich da nicht von einer speziellen Kulturtechnik eher reden. Sondern das ist die Natur.
Wobei ja aber trotzdem, das sich noch ein bisschen geändert hat, weil im Zeitalter des Ketten und Tapes war es ja sozusagen also schon, dass man eine Kopie, die relativ verlustfrei war, sage ich mal, machen konnte. Aber dennoch benötigte es den physikalischen Kontakt. Und das ist ja mit dem Internet völlig aufgehoben. Also man stellt es ja irgendwo hin und dann kann es quasi jeder haben.
Ja, so entwickelt sich das halt weiter. Aber das Ziel ist ja immer noch dasselbe. Also dieses Zur-Verfügung-Stellen einer digitalen Kopie, das ist ja schon auch noch eine Errungenschaft der neuen Zeit. Definitiv.
Was sind denn jetzt also die Fragen, die wir den geneigten Leuten stellen würden, die jetzt die 03317797110 anrufen?
Ja, also uns wollen unterschiedliche Sachen interessieren. Also einerseits natürlich, wenn ihr jetzt konkret schon vielleicht lange Zeit Chaosradio hört, auch sozusagen über die gesamte Zeit, Eindrücke und Einschätzungen, was weiß ich, also wo lang wir richtig, wo lang wir falsch, meinetwegen, wenn euch sowas einfällt, darum geht es uns, sollten wir mehr Musik reden und aufhören zu reden. Oder vielleicht wo für euch auch eine Aussage oder ein Thema von Chaosradio mal besondere Einsichten gebracht hat oder wo entgegengesetzt, wo wir unter Umständen total daneben lagen. Aber keine Ahnung, sowas würde uns natürlich auf jeden Fall sehr interessieren. Und im Kontext der Sendung. Und dann natürlich noch so Dinge, so Fragen wie Ja, wie habt ihr, was ist für euch eine erworbene Kulturtechnik? Also wo hat sozusagen das Leben mit Technik sich für euch so verselbstständigt? Um mal ein Beispiel zu nennen, also sowas wie eine E-Mail schreiben. Ich weiß noch, das war einfach vor 20 Jahren oder auch vor 15 Jahren war das noch so E-Mail schreiben. Wenn man das jemand so gesagt hat, da wurde man einfach genauso komisch angeguckt, wie vor 20 Jahren ein Handy haben. Ja, was bist du denn für einer und wovon redest du denn? Ach ja, bist du wichtig, dass du mit dem Telefon rumlaufen musst? Lalalalala. Ja, sowas würde ja heute kein Mensch mehr...
Ich habe ja...
und was ist genau? Und die Frage natürlich, was vermisst man? Was ist vielleicht verloren gegangen? Was ist dazugekommen? Was ist an unverzichtbaren Dingen dazugekommen? Das waren auch so Fragen. Und was sind jetzt natürlich speziell Kulturtechniken auch im Chaos-Umfeld? Das ist natürlich auch so ein Thema, weil das sind ja nicht beliebige Kulturtechniken, sondern der ganze Begriff Hacker-Szene und kreative Technikbeherrschung und kreativer Umgang mit Technik. Welche Kulturtechniken hätten sich vielleicht gar nicht entwickelt, wenn da nicht so ein kreativer Freiraum auch gewesen wäre, um bis an die Grenzen zu gehen. Also was ist vielleicht auch der große Nutzen? Ich meine, neulich war ja auch schon ein paar Tage her die Preisverleihung. Da wurde ja der Chaos Computer Club quasi auch schon als kulturelles Artefakt geadelt, wenn man so will. Insofern ist auch da natürlich der ganze Technikkultur Zusammenhang.
Das hört sich aber eher wie eine Beleidigung an Kultur Artefakt. Aber wenn ihr dazu was zu sagen habt, dann wie gesagt gerne das hier tun. Jetzt anrufen! 0331 70 97 110 Was ich ja auch spannend finde, ist die Kulturtechnik der Interaktion. Ich weiß nicht mal, ob es so nennen kann, weil das Internet ist ja damals auch angetreten und tut es auch immer noch mit dem großen jetzt dürfen endlich alle auf Augenhöhe miteinander reden. Und was man feststellt, sind Sendungen oder Dinge, die genau dafür gemacht sind. Also Leute, die früher nicht das Zeug hatten oder nicht die Möglichkeiten hatten, zu senden und dann mit Leuten zu reden, machen das und dann ruft keiner an oder kommentiert keiner. Vielleicht sind die in dieser Hinsicht auch total überschätzt.
Das ist eine gute Frage und das ist auch eine Frage, die wir uns auch gestellt haben. Ob wir uns auch selbst nicht, also haben wir bestimmt, kann ich gleich mal vorweggreifen, vor allem auch wo man sich selbst überschätzt hat. Was mir so eingefallen ist, Timothy Leary, dieser Prophet der LSD-Generation, der hat ja dann, was weiß ich hier, mit so Tune-In, Turn-On, Drop-Out und seinen Thesen mit, man muss ja nur genug LSD ins Trinkwasser kippen, dann würden dann alle sich zu so einem Higher-State entwickeln. Also sozusagen, wenn wir nur alle genug LSD nehmen, dann würde eben auch so eine menschliche Evolution einsetzen auf Basis dieser Hirnbefreiung, das war jetzt so seine These, die sozusagen die Gesellschaft selbst dann einen Schritt weiterbringt. Hat so jetzt nicht stattgefunden, wobei man sagen muss, Timothy Leary hat es halt immerhin geschafft, im Orbit bestattet zu werden, das muss man ja auch erstmal hinkriegen. Und wenn man das aber jetzt mal so diese Idee überträgt auf diese Technikgeneration, die ja auch eine extrem technisch verliebte Generation ist, die auch häufig diesen Fehler macht, das ist etwas, was ich gerade bei Hackern auch sehr häufig erlebe, dass man eben so Ursache und Zweck und so weiter, dass man das alles verwechselt, dass man zu sehr von der Technik her denkt, ja, so, oh, jetzt habe ich dieses Gerät, das kann folgende Dinge tun. Und dann denkt man sich irgendetwas aus, wie irgendwas funktionieren könnte, aber auf Basis der Funktionalität des Gerätes. Und man lässt dabei vollkommen außer Acht, was es eigentlich letzten Endes wirklich tun sollte, um Akzeptanz zu finden. Ich glaube, da sind auch viele Anwendungen im Internet am Anfang daran gescheitert, dass sie einfach von Technikern ausgedacht waren, die nicht wirklich vom Benutzer her gedacht haben.
Daran scheitern heute noch die meisten Mobiltelefone.
Ja, gutes Beispiel. User Interfaces. Jeder, der mal von so einem Videorecorder gekniet hat, wo einfach in 99% der Fälle das User Interface von einem Ingenieur gemacht wurde. Menü, Hauptmenü, Submenü, Fax Systemeinstellungen, System Setup, System Special Setup, Extensions, Add-ons, Plug-ins. Du wirst irgendwie konfrontiert mit so einer Denkwelt, der man überhaupt gar nicht mehr folgen kann. Dabei willst du einfach nur das scheiß Teil faxen.
Aber ist dann auch eine Kulturtechnik, irgendwie diese Geräte mit den wenigen Knöpfen und kruden Displays und schlechten Bedienungsanleitungen dazu zu bringen, das zu tun, was sie sollen. Das kennt, glaube ich, jeder, auch diesen Horror, so manchmal so einem technischen Gerät entgegenzutreten und jetzt zu überlegen, wie ging das nochmal. Und dann ewig lange irgendwelche Knöpfe drückt, bis es dann...
Wobei ich den Eindruck habe, dass genau das ein Problem ist, dass sozusagen die Neuerschaffung von Kulturtechnik vorausgesetzt wurde, dass Geräte wurden zu lange gebaut von Leuten, die gebaut haben, was möglich ist. Und dann kamen irgendwann Leute, die haben Dinge gebaut, die man benutzen kann. Also ich finde, Google ist ein sehr schönes Beispiel, die ja jetzt technisch keine wirklich Neuerungen angeboten haben, außer mehr Speicherplatz, aber halt einfach mal ein E-Mail-Interface an den Start gebracht haben, das jeder verstanden hat.
Du redest jetzt von Gmail?
Von Gmail, genau, erstmal.
Nicht von Google, die Suche.
Ja, aber die eigentlich auch ein gutes Beispiel ist. Naja, wir bauen ein Interface mal so, dass es funktioniert.
Google ist ganz interessant, weil Google ist eigentlich für mich immer so ein bisschen genau an der Grenze. Weil auf der einen Seite ist es eine totale Nerdbude, die auch erhebliches Failpotenzial hat. Gerade wenn man sich im letzten Jahr angeschaut hat, was sie alles versucht haben, an den Start zu bringen, was teilweise kolossal gescheitert ist. Also ihre Umtriebe in Social Networks, da Orkut kann man eigentlich weitgehend als gescheitert ansehen, auch wenn die Brasilianer das noch ganz toll finden. Das wird aber auch nicht mehr so lange halten. Gerade jetzt Google Wave, frisch beerdigt, war auch ein Technologietraum. Da hat man alles reingepackt, was irgendwie ging. Ja, ist irgendwie Chat, ist irgendwie E-Mail, ist irgendwie Wiki, ist irgendwie das und es ist alles. Und es ist toll, und es ist toll, weil es alles ist. Und dann ist es aber unter dieser Last, alles zu sein, förmlich ineinander zusammengebrochen, weil nämlich niemand mehr wusste, was es denn nun eigentlich lieber sein möchte. Ist es jetzt Kommunikation oder ist es Kollaboration? Ist es irgendwie mehr sowas wie E-Mail, wo man einmal was schreibt und dann überträgt man das und dann wird es gelesen? Oder ist es eher sowas wie ein Wiki, wo man das an einem Ort gemeinsam schreibt? Und es ist auch mehr um dieses Gemeinsam. Also es war, alles war irgendwie offen und nichts war klar.
Keiner wusste so richtig, was er damit machen soll.
Genau, und daran ist es dann auch gescheitert, zumal es sich natürlich auch technisch nicht beherrschen lässt, wenn du gar nicht mehr weißt, welchen Aspekt du nun eigentlich weiterentwickeln sollst. Weil du eben mit zu viel angefangen hast. Im Gegensatz dazu kann man sowas sehen wie Twitter, was mit einer extremen Reduktion an den Start gegangen ist, auch wenn es heute für etwas ganz anderes eingesetzt wird und sich in eine Richtung entwickelt, für die es ursprünglich mal so nicht unbedingt gedacht war, aber trotzdem taugt, weil diese einfache Idee mit, ich hab da meinen Status und ich veröffentliche den, plus dieses mega kongeniale, weltenumstürzende Konzept des Followers, das haben wir einfach Twitter zu verdanken, das kopiert jeder jetzt, weil es einfach total sinnvoll ist und auf einmal ist ein Werkzeug geschaffen, auf das viele Leute gar nicht mehr verzichten müssen.
Googlen und twittern können sind auch Kulturtechniken, die ganz elementar wichtig sind. Wie finde ich mithilfe einer Suchmaschine, da ist Google nun mal die beste und größte, das, was ich eigentlich will, einer der wichtigsten Kulturtechniken heutzutage, und mit Twitter, wie organisiere ich mir meine Kommunikation?
Ich habe ja manchmal immer auch den Eindruck, Twitter sei eher so eine Subkulturtechnik, die von Leuten benutzt wird, die viele Netzteile unterwegs sind, aber nicht eine Kulturtechnik in dem Sinne, dass sie wirklich von allen benutzt wird. Ich glaube, da ist Google schon eher ein gutes Beispiel und Facebook wird es glaube ich langsam, aber sicher egal, ob man das will oder nicht. Wir haben Patrick am Telefon, der etwas über das Chaosradio sagen will. Patrick, Abend.
Ja, grüß euch.
Der Chaosradio ist eine Kulturtechnik, oder hat sie beeinflusst?
Sehr stark sogar, würde ich sagen. Also ich muss sagen, ich hab Chaosradio, als ich dann irgendwann mal Internet hatte, erstmal über AOL, dann über die Uni und irgendwann mal wächst man dann halt aus der ganzen Sache raus. Und hört halt im Chaosradio AOL ist böse oder was weiß ich und hört sich das mal alles mal so an. Und kommt auf neue Gedanken, probiert dies, probiert das. Ist dann zum Hacken gekommen, hat dann Nächte verbracht, um ein bisschen ins Programmieren reinzuarbeiten. Und letztendlich habe ich dann mein Elektrotechnikstudium abgebrochen und bin jetzt Softwareentwickler und das hauptsächlich auf FritzWert.
Und da ist Chaosradio dran schuld?
Mitunter, ja. Mit Sicherheit.
Mit Sicherheit?
Warum? Weil man viele neue Ideen hört, die man halt ausprobiert, selber sich hinsetzt und guckt, was ist das denn? Und dass man dann letztendlich mehr interessiert hat, als was im Studium da gelabert wird. Da ging es dann halt letztendlich, ich kann mich am Vordeplome erinnern, wo ich mich durch eine Prüfung gequält habe, was mich echt absolut nicht interessiert hat, elektrische Maschinen und Antriebe. Ich wollte an der Haustasse Mikroelektronik studieren. Und durch die Prüfung bin ich ein paar Mal durchgerauscht, wahrscheinlich auch, weil ich mich mit anderen Dingen beschäftigt habe, die halt gerade im Chaosradio dann besprochen worden sind.
Das Chaosradio als Prokrastinationsmaschine also?
Genau so. Aber man hat dann so viele Skills erworben, dass man halt in einem Unternehmen unersetzlich geworden ist.
Das heißt, man kann mittlerweile in seinen Lebenslauf reinschreiben, habe 10 Jahre Chaosradio gehört?
Ja, ich habe alle Folgen gehört, die verfügbar sind.
Ernsthaft?
Einige sogar mehrfach. Ich habe ja irgendwann mal angefangen, als kleiner Junge auf dem C64 zu programmieren. Also so Peak und Poke und die ganzen Sachen. Und als das dann auch langweilig wurde, habe ich dann kurz mal in ein Sender reingeguckt. Dann war halt lange Zeit irgendwie Pause, weil ich irgendwie kein neues Gerät bekommen habe. Damals hat mir mein Vater das Gerät gekauft, diesen Commodore 64, und dann kam halt lange Zeit nichts. Also kein neues Gerät. Also fährt mal auf den Press am neuen Gerät. Kam halt lange Zeit nichts. Ich hatte keine Atari oder PC. Und dann habe ich erst 1995 halt meinen ersten Windows 95 Rechner gehabt. Zum Studium. Und der wurde dann halt relativ schnell umgebaut auf eine Linux-Kiste. Und so kommt halt eins zum anderen.
Darf ich fragen, wie alt du jetzt bist? Beziehungsweise 35. Okay, also hast du mit 20 Jahren angefangen reinzuhören.
Jetzt ist ja die Sachen, die du gemacht hast mit dem Rechner, sind dir zwar, würde ich sagen, den meisten Hörern dieser Sendung wahrscheinlich irgendwie vertraut. Aber Kulturtechnik im weiteren Sinne, also wie hat die Technik unser Leben in den letzten 15 Jahren verändert? Was fällt dir dazu als erstes ein?
Dazu fällt mir ein, dass sich sowohl Chaosradio, als auch Chaosradio Express komplett gewandelt haben. Ich finde, da sind zunehmend soziale Aspekte mit reingeflochten.
Entschuldigung, was für Aspekte?
Soziale.
Soziale, ja.
Also sozialpolitisch und Kultur. Also ich kann mich auch erinnern, dass ich dann irgendwann mal in Chaosradio Express gehört habe. Mit Tim Trittner, mit Tuja Ernuff und der Juli C. Wo ich dann zu Weihnachten von meinem Bruder das Buch dazu und die CD geschenkt bekommen soll.
Okay, jetzt wär es wirklich hilfreich, wenn du sagen würdest, worum es geht.
Es ging um die Sendung Chaosradio Express 135, Mut zur Freiheit.
Und da ging es worum?
Da ging es genau darum. Die Arteure von Juli C sind ja Autoren. Die haben ein Buch geschrieben. Das war damals in dieser ganzen Debatte um Netzsperren auch ein Thema. Da ging es generell um die Diskussion, die wir jetzt haben mit der ganzen Terrorgeschichte. Will man lieber in Angst leben oder hat man einfach Mut zur Freiheit? Darauf spielst du jetzt gerade an auf diese Sendung.
Wir hatten früher zumindest mal den Rhythmus abwechselnd eine technische und eine politische Sendung zu machen. Insofern ist es sicherlich jetzt nicht ganz verständlich, dass man in andere Politikbereiche natürlich auch reinguckt.
Aber vielleicht schon eine spannende Frage, die wir noch weiter verfolgen könnten. Die Frage, ob es in je weiter Zeit voranschritt, mehr um kulturelle Auswirkungen von Technik als um Technik selber geht, einfach weil die Technik irgendwann angefangen hat so gut zu funktionieren, dass man sie tatsächlich benutzen konnte. Was sich nicht geändert hat in den 15 Jahren Chaosradio ist, sind die kurzen Unterbrechungen, die man zum Beispiel machen muss, weil es Nachrichten gibt. Fritz Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr jetzt gleich. Danach geht es weiter mit Kulturtechnik und Technikultur.
Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Am 25. November, das ist ein letzter Donnerstag im Monat, das heißt Chaosradio. Diesmal zum 15-jährigen Jubiläum geht es zusammen mit Tim Prittloff und Pavel Meier um Kulturtechniken und Technikultur und all den Unfug, den das Chaosradio in den vergangenen 15 Jahren so getrieben hat. Ist das richtig zusammengefasst?
Ja, früher haben wir immer gesagt, der Chaos Computer Club ist zu Gast. Jetzt sind wir schon mehr so die alten Honorigen. Aber wir haben ja noch den Patrick in der Leitung, ne?
Das stimmt, da geht es gerade um die Frage, inwieweit Kultur und Technik zusammengehören und inwieweit die Technik uns auch beeinflusst hat.
Ich habe das Gefühl, du hast noch nicht eine. Patrick, bist du noch da? Du hast vorhin auf die Sendung jetzt mit der Ulysee und so weiter angesprochen. Ich weiß nicht, ob du da deinen eigentlichen Punkt schon rübergebracht hattest. Ich hatte nicht so den Eindruck.
Ja, man kann da noch mehr zu sagen. Beispielsweise hast du ja dann irgendwann mal die Wikipedia-Sendung gemacht im Chaos Radio. Und da wurde dann das erste Mal irgendwie interaktiv im IRC auch noch gechattet. Das fand ich auch schon sehr bewegend, weil Wikipedia ist sicherlich auch so ein Stück Kultur, was man so in der Geschichte erstellt hatte, sag ich mal. Und da wurde dann quasi live im Chaos Radio, wurden dann Links geschickt und ausgetauscht. Die dann auch wieder in die Sendung eingeschlossen sind. Und da hat wahrscheinlich auch Wikipedia in Deutschland gewissen Bekanntheitsgrad durch das Radio.
Ja, das war eine super Sendung, die kann ich jedem echt nur empfehlen. Also das, ich glaube, ehrlich gesagt, das ist mein persönliches Highlight. Ich glaube, das war eine der besten Sendungen, die wir überhaupt jemals gemacht haben, weil die war so was von mega interaktiv und spannend, weil da wurde ja so richtig so live editiert, live gesperrt und so weiter. Wir konnten so richtig so am glühenden kochenden Ofen sozusagen live erklären, wie Wikipedia funktioniert mit all dieser Dynamik bei den Admins damals. Und damals kannte das halt noch keiner. Also es war 2004, da gab es das mal seit drei Jahren, aber hatte noch nicht im Ansatz die Bedeutung, die es mittlerweile genießt.
Was aber vielleicht auch ein Punkt ist, den man auch bei anderen Sachen mal betrachten könnte, ist, dass ja die Wikipedia über die Jahre hinweg dann den Ruf eines Kaninzenzüchtervereins bekommen hat, weil die Chaosradio Sendung über die Wikipedia, die ich mitgemacht habe, wo auch Pawel hier war, da ging es ja um die Relevanzdebatte. Also darum, dass dieses freie Interaktive gar nicht mehr so möglich ist, weil es diese riesen Streit darum gibt, wer jetzt was reinschreiben darf, ob es da stehen bleiben darf und ob überhaupt. Da wäre natürlich spannend zu sehen, ob das...
Das ist ein interessanter Punkt, weil hier reden wir nämlich eigentlich über die Kulturtechnik Online Encyclopädie. Die ist halt erst vor ein paar Jahren überhaupt erst erfunden worden. Die ist halt einfach noch nicht so drin, wie jetzt heute E-Mail oder das Feuer machen. Das befindet sich eigentlich noch im freien Kampf. Und ich glaube, dass auch jetzt der aktuelle Zustand da auch nur ein Zwischenstand ist und mit dem Ergebnis in fünf bis zehn Jahren und darüber hinaus wird es sicherlich auch noch viel Bewegung geben, ja, gar nicht zu vergleichen ist.
Ja, sich in der Wikipedia zurecht zu finden und Artikel zu bearbeiten. Sicherlich auch so eine Kulturtechnik auf jeden Fall. Mir ist aber gerade noch bei der Nachrichten, bei den Nachrichten ist mir noch aufgefallen, dass manche Themen irgendwie dann doch nicht weggehen. Immer wenn man glaubt, sie wären weg, also so dann poppt es wieder hoch. Also ich kann mich erinnern, dass wir, ich weiß nicht, vor sieben, acht, neun Jahren hier auch schon gesessen haben in Zeiten der Terrordrohungen und des Terrorwarns und des Terrormarketings. Und jetzt, also auch das Thema, ich komm mir vor, ich mein wie in so einer Zeitschleife.
Ja, ja ist so. Chaosradio 65, der Terror und die Freiheit, das war unsere Sendung nach dem 11. September, zwei Wochen danach.
Da sind wir wieder, hallo.
Und ich glaub, die Argumente sind immer noch dieselben und die kreisen immer noch und es ist immer noch so, da haben wir so Regierende, die uns permanent irgendwie in so eine Angst eintauchen wollen, weil sie selber auch irgendwie in der Arsch auf Grundeis geht aus Gründen, die wir nicht nachvollziehen können und die letzten Endes durch ihr merkwürdiges Gehabe genau das erzeugen, was nämlich der Terror ja eigentlich bezweckt, nämlich uns sozusagen unsere Freiheit zu nehmen beziehungsweise uns in Angst einzutauchen und dadurch zu lähmen.
Aber die gute Nachricht daran ist doch eigentlich, wenn das schon damals so war, dann müssten wir quasi also fast nichts befürchten, weil es passiert ja eh immer nur dasselbe.
Naja, aber es werden diese Freiheiten ja auch eingeschränkt und es ist ja auch so, dass gerade derzeit einfach gerade die damals noch vorherrschende und fast unnahbare Freiheit im Netz zunehmendem Maße genommen werden soll. Also wir hören uns nur an, was gerade jetzt für Thesen wieder gebracht worden sind. Na ja, man müsste ja mal die Pressefreiheit einschränken und überhaupt das mit dieser Anonymität im Internet, das geht ja nun überhaupt nicht. Ja, das ist auch so ein wiederkehrendes Mem. Wobei das wahrscheinlich noch die geringste Bedrohung ist. Aber das sind halt alles so Dinge, die dann eben schrittweise auch dazu führen. Oder jetzt was unmittelbar bevorsteht, die Verabschiedung des Jugendmediendienstes Staatsvertrages. Wo dann so Absurditäten hinkommen, dass ich an meinen Blog dran schreiben muss, ab wieviel Jahre das ist. Und wenn das dann irgendwie nicht ab 18 ist, dann darf das nur tagsüber gesendet werden.
Entschuldigung, kann man in deinem Blog kommentieren?
Ja, natürlich.
Das ist ja grundsätzlich ab 18.
Ja, das ist völlig ein hanebüchener Quatsch. Und mit so einem Scheiß trauen die sich nicht nur auf die Bühne, sondern die trauen sich tatsächlich da noch tagelang und monatelang und wochenlang in aller Öffentlichkeit Gesetze nicht nur zu bereden, sondern dann auch noch zu beschließen, die einfach wirkungslos sind und die einfach in ihren Auswirkungen und Nebenwirkungen vor allem katastrophal sind. Und da möchte man sich schonend auch immer wieder, das ist so ein bisschen und täglich grüßt das Murmeltier. Das ist glaube ich das, was du meinst. Man wacht immer wieder morgens um 6 auf, der Wecker spielt dasselbe Lied und so, kommt wieder so ja und die Innenminister und die Terrorangst und überhaupt und die Bedrohung ist groß und wir können euch nicht genau sagen, was los ist, aber irgendwie gibt es eine Sicherheitsschwankung und bitte geht jetzt wieder nicht aus dem Haus und übrigens, wir müssen mal eure Freiheiten einschränken, weil wo kommen wir denn da hin?
Aber ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, das hört man tatsächlich immer wieder und man hat aber auch das Gefühl, die Leute da draußen, wer auch immer das ist, sozusagen wählen sich nicht und da gibt es eine Kulturtechnik, die uns vielleicht noch fehlt und die würde mich interessieren, warum die nicht gelernt wird, Medienkompetenz. Also im weitesten Sinne. Es ist sozusagen, es gibt ja, also man kann jetzt sozusagen verschiedene politische Meinungen sein, aber gerade was die Einschränkung dieser ganzen Dinge angeht, das ist ja häufig so, wenn man länger mit Leuten redet und denen mal vorne und hinten erklärt, dass die dann sagen, hm, stimmt eigentlich, aber das passiert halt nicht. Also ist das verhindert vielleicht, die neue Technik auch die Entstehung von Medienkompetenz, weil sie so Oberfläche ist und uns zu viel bewirft. Ich würde jetzt gerne den Marcel dazu nehmen. Der will dir nicht was zu Kulturtechnik im Mainstream sagen. Vielleicht hat das damit zu tun. Marcel, guten Abend.
Schönen guten Abend. Ich wollte mal die These in den Raum werfen, dass wir eigentlich das ganze Thema ziemlich überschätzen und gar nicht in unserer Technikblase gar nicht so wirklich, vielleicht täglich uns genug bewusst machen, wie abgekapselt wir in unserer Technikblase dann auch wirklich von der Realität sind.
Mit wir meinst du jetzt?
Mit wir meine ich so die ganze Netzgemeinde, die auf Twitter unterwegs ist, die Blogs liest und die ganzen Netzthemen einfach mitbekommt, die glaube ich so in der realen Welt oder in der restlichen Welt gar nicht so ankommen. Also wenn ich mir, weiß ich nicht, die Netzmeinung zu dem Terrorthema angucke, naja, dann ist das einfach eine komplett andere zu der, des Mainstreams der Leute da draußen.
Aber woher kommt das, weil die Technologie stellt es ja eigentlich zur Verfügung, dass jeder dieselben Informationen haben kann?
Die Technologie ja, aber dafür brauche ich ja auch das Wissen und ja die Erfahrung mit meinem Umgang damit und ich glaube, da haben wir es einfach.
Man kriegt ja das meiste über das Fernsehen mit. Also ich hab's erlebt, ich hab jetzt zu meinem, zu dem Geburtstag von meinem Patenkind, hab ich mein Patenkind mal angerufen und hab gefragt, wie es so geht und so. Und dann kam er dann irgendwie, wenn man das Angst vor Terror hat, zehn Jahre, war nicht so, warum, kam halt im Fernsehen. Und der hört halt nicht Chaosradio.
Aber du als dein Partneronkel bist da gefordert, ist ja klar.
Ja, genau. Ich hab ihm gesagt, du brauchst es für nichts, Angst zu haben.
Also als Zehnjähriger hab ich auch überall Raftterroristen gesehen, kann ich mich noch ganz gut dran erinnern, als Kinder dann auch. Also das ganze Fernsehen, alles war voll, alle redeten irgendwie von Terroristen, die irgendwie Leute erschießen und entführen und so. Und mitten in der Provinz so als Acht- oder Neunjährige haben wir irgendwie auch überall Terroristen gesehen. Und das Drücken von Angstknöpfen funktioniert auf jeden Fall, immer haben wir jetzt festgestellt. Auch wenn man weiß, man weiß es ja eben nicht wirklich, das heißt als skeptischer Mensch kann man sich ja nie sicher sein. So und deswegen funktioniert das einfach, weil man stellt plötzlich fest, man kann nicht anders als wenn man irgendwo einen Koffer umsieht, plötzlich irgendwo an Terror zu denken oder das Wort Koffer überhaupt nur hört. So das hat dann plötzlich eine ganz andere Assoziation auf einmal hervor.
Man kann sich heute auf den Hauptbahnhof stellen und laut schreien, da steht ein Koffer.
Heute wurde irgendwie so ein polnischer Sperrmüllsammler hochgenommen, der einfach nur seine Tasche kurz abgestellt hat auf dem Bahnhof und dann ging es halt los. Und das ist halt schon...
Früher hat man solche Koffer einfach zum Fundbüro gebracht. Was auch sonst?
Oder stehen lassen einfach, bis derjenige gekommen ist und sich den wieder abgeholt hat.
Koffer stehen lassen, ja. Ich glaube, was passiert mit dem Weihnachtsmann, der hat ja ziemlich viele Pakete immer dabei.
Osama bin Laden hat auch einen Bart. Der Weihnachtsmann vielleicht ist... Vielleicht haben sie ihn deshalb nicht gekriegt, weil der Weihnachtsmann Osama bin Laden ist.
Vom Weihnachtsmann mit dem Bart nochmal zurück, Marcel.
Osama ist in Finnland.
Um mal wieder ein bisschen Ernsthaftigkeit in die Sache zu bringen. Ich glaube halt, dass das Netz die Möglichkeit bietet, sich mit solchen Themen einfach auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise auseinanderzusetzen. Also wenn ich vom Fernseher sitze als 40-Jähriger, der nicht unbedingt viel im Netz unterwegs ist und ich sehe eine Call-In-Show, dann kann ich mir da zu meinem Teil denken und gegebenenfalls an meinem Stammtisch mich noch damit auseinandersetzen. Im Internet wird das Ganze aber ganz anders auseinandergenommen. Da wird das analysiert, da habe ich die Möglichkeit, mir Videozusammenschnitte anzugucken, Blogbeiträge darüber zu lesen und mich einfach in Themen viel tiefer zu, einfach viel mehr zu vertiefen, was ich offline nicht die Möglichkeit dazu habe. Und ich glaube, daher kommt einfach auch so eine andere, ein Stück weit eine andere Aufgeklärtheit, die ich offline einfach nicht genießen kann.
Ja, oft sind die Kommentare ja wichtiger als der Artikel. Und wenn ich hier sehe, da schreibt jemand einfach kompletten Mist, dann kann ich da halt drunter schreiben, warum das kompletter Mist ist, was da steht. Und das geht natürlich im Fernsehen nicht so leicht, wenn da halt irgendwelche Sendungen rüber geschwappt kommen. Hab ich gerade nur den Ausschalt habe. Ansonsten, ja, gut, oder Twitter.
Da ist ja reingekommen jetzt in diese Diskussion mit der Frage, sind wir nur in einer Blase und warum können wir nicht mit dem Rest kommunizieren, wenn ich die richtig verstanden habe, Marcel?
Ja, so ein Stück weit schon. Beziehungsweise da denke ich auch ein Stück weit Vorreiter. Wir reden ja auch immer von dem interaktiven Fernsehen, was bestimmt eines Jahres mal kommt.
Und Videotelefonie, genau. Die ewige Zukunftstechnologie.
Also wenn ich mir den Umgang meiner Eltern mit dem Internet angucke, dann sind die inzwischen da angekommen, wo man ein bisschen Online-Banking machen kann. Hin und wieder wird auch mal irgendwie eine E-Mail beantwortet, was aber sehr sehr selten ist, weil wenn man den Rechner ausgeschaltet hat, dann bekommt man davon nichts mit, was ja für unser eins unvorstellbar ist, weil es irgendwie an drei Geräten gleichzeitig bümmelt. Bei meinen Eltern ist das Internet als Nachschlagemedium so langsam angekommen. Das ist so der Schritt, den man vor, weiß ich nicht, vor 15 Jahren wieder der Rest halt gemacht.
Ich möchte nur kurz einwerfen, das war jetzt gerade Videotelefonie und Eltern, die keinen Plan haben. Meine Großeltern haben mich neulich per Video auf Skype angerufen.
Die Videotelefonie kommt jetzt auch gerade wirklich.
Ja, das denke ich schon seit 15 Jahren.
Ich kann mir so vorstellen, dass in 10, 15 Jahren auch meine Eltern und ihre Generation wirklich aktiv gegebenenfalls mit kommunizieren und diskutieren bei Themen und so. So diesen reinen Empfängerplatz da verlassen und auch mit senden und mit produzieren.
Das finde ich aber, das habe ich mich gerade schon gefragt. Glaubst du das wirklich, dass die Sichtbarkeit solcher Themen einfach durch Technik erhöht wird?
Inwiefern die Sichtbarkeit?
Na ja, du sagst ja gerade deine Eltern werden vielleicht in 15 Jahren auch darüber diskutieren. Das glaube ich halt nicht, weil Eltern im Sinne von Leute, die geschlossene technische Systeme nur dann benutzen, wenn sie genau da sind, nämlich geschlossen und halbwegs bedienbar, kommen ja an diese Themen nicht ran.
Ich glaube, seine Eltern spielen ja überhaupt keine Rolle, weil Eltern sterben halt irgendwann. Wichtig ist ja sozusagen, was danach kommt.
Na gut, aber es ist insofern schon relevant, weil es ist die Frage, ob wir da, wo die Netzgemeinde heute ist, ob wir da in 10, 20 oder 50 Jahren sein wollen. Bis meine Elterngeneration komplett ausgestorben ist und der Mainstream aus der jetzigen Generation besteht, dauert das ja noch einen Moment.
Ich möchte noch kurz unterbrechen diese Elterngeschichte. Diese Eltern sind für mich nur Platzhalter für Leute, die das Netz genau nicht dazu nutzen, diese reichhaltigen Informationen, sozusagen sich an den Start zu schaffen. Und ich glaube nicht, dass das eine Altersfrage ist.
Ich glaube schon, dass es eine Altersfrage ist.
Na auch.
Aber es gibt auch in unserem und noch jüngeren Alter Leute, die einfach genau keinen Plan haben und die genau einfach mal irgendwie auf Facebook alles reinwerfen und sich später wundern, Entschuldigung, wie es denn jetzt passiert.
Aber sie sind immerhin auf Facebook. Also das mag jetzt nicht gut sein, dass sie auf Facebook sind und wissen, was sie tun, aber sie sind im Internet angekommen und bekommen auf Facebook auf jeden Fall schon mal mit, dass man auch aktiv mitdiskutieren kann und dass da gegebenenfalls eine ganz neue Kultur, da sind wir wieder beim Thema, eine ganz neue Kultur, entsteht. Und meine Eltern oder meine Elterngeneration, die hat einfach nicht den Druck auf Facebook zu sein, weil all ihre Mitschüler auf Facebook sind, weil die gibt es entsprechend nicht. Und ich glaube, deswegen wird die jüngere Generation einfach von selbst an das Thema rangeführt, was über diesen Kanal halt nicht funktioniert. Aber aufgrund dessen, dass meine Eltern inzwischen immerhin das Internet nutzen, um mal Online-Bänken zu machen und was nachzuschlagen, habe ich ja die Hoffnung, dass in 10, 15 Jahren vielleicht die Themen auch sich so weit hochgespielt haben, dass dann auch da vielleicht aktiv mit kommuniziert wird.
Das ist aber schon sozusagen so eine Art Technik-Gläubigkeit, die du hast. Du sagst schon, wenn nur viele Genäute lang genug im Internet unterwegs sind, dann werden sie irgendwann auch mit diesen Themen in Berührung kommen und sich ausführlich informieren.
Ja, also ich glaube, dass diese Schnelllebigkeit des Internets, also nicht beispielsweise beim mobilen Internetzugang, das war vor fünf Jahren, war das was, was gerade so ging. Heute hat das irgendwie jeder, der auch einen Twitter-Account hat. Und ich denke mal, in fünf bis zehn Jahren wächst die Technikwelt in die höheren Generationen mit. Wenn ich irgendwann, also ich werde ja auch dazu gezwungen, damit zu machen, irgendwann kann ich kein Handy und keinen Tarif mehr kaufen, der kein Internet hat, weil es einfach Standard ist, genauso wie ich irgendwann auf einmal keine Steuererklärung mehr schriftlich abgeben konnte, weil es einfach elektronisch Standard geworden ist. Und so werde ich ja auch, wenn ich gar nicht will, gezwungen, da mitzumachen. Früher ist man auch noch zum Schalter gegangen, heute kostet das Gebühren und darüber werde ich gezwungen, näher an den Automaten zu gehen. Deswegen glaube ich, drückt die Technik sich dann einfach irgendwann in die höheren Generationen.
Weil mir noch auffällt, gerade so eine Kulturtechnik, oder die meisten Kulturtechniken, zeichnen sich auch dazu, dass sie im Curriculum, also im Lehrplan, irgendeiner Schule oder vielleicht sogar der allgemeinbildenden Schulen auftauchen. Und da ist von den neuen Kulturtechniken noch nicht so richtig viel angekommen. Ich merke das zum Beispiel daran, dass meiner Tochter gestern das Mobiltelefon in der Schule konfisziert wurde, weil es im Unterricht geklingelt hat. Und da läuft es so, da ist mir aufgefallen, dass du in der Schule eben dieses Always-on nicht... Also da lebt man noch ein anderes Leben. Also Schule funktioniert zum Beispiel ohne Internet. Das ist eine ganz komische künstliche Welt. Weil in der Firma zu arbeiten ohne Internet, also insofern ist das halt... Überhaupt zu arbeiten ohne Internet. Überhaupt zu arbeiten ohne Internet, aber in der Schule...
Ich könnte mir das auch nicht mehr vorstellen, auf der Schule zu sein. Also das haben wir vorhin schon ein bisschen über die Vergangenheit nachgedacht. Ob diese Vergangenheit überhaupt so lebenswert wäre. Ich hab festgestellt, dass allein schon die Internet-Situation der Vergangenheit sie nämlich komplett unbewohnbar macht. Da möchte ich nie wieder sein in dieser Zeit.
Aber ich glaube, bei diesem Schulbeispiel an den Schülern wird ja nicht liegen. Die würden das ja gerne auch soweit nutzen. Aber ich glaube, da reden wir nochmal von komplett anderen kulturellen Veränderungen. Weil sich dadurch ja auch das komplette Schulbild ein Stück weit ändern müsste. Weil ich muss ja dem Schüler, wenn ich ihm, weiß ich nicht, in fünf Jahren dauerhaften Zugang während der Unterrichtszeit zum Internet anbieten möchte, muss ich ihm ja auch soweit vertrauen, dass er dann noch irgendwie am Unterricht teilnimmt und nicht nur auf Facebook ist. Oder Facebook vielleicht dann so nutzt, dass es dem Schulunterricht dient. Also ich glaube, das ist ja nicht nur eine reine Technikakzeptanz. Das geht vielleicht noch ein bisschen weiter.
Ja, das ist eine Frage. Jetzt sind wir wieder genau bei dem Ding. Jetzt haben wir gerade eben viel über Technik, Kultur geredet. So dieses Navier mit dem Internet. Und wir wissen ja, wie das geht. Und wir wissen ja irgendwie, alles zu machen. Aber die Eltern, die verstehen das nicht. Was halt eigentlich, sagen wir mal, das große Metathema ist der letzten 15 Jahre, ist so eine Hauptkulturtechnik. Diskutieren und Meinungsbildung und Information im oder mit dem Netz. Das ist, wenn man das mal überlegt, eigentlich ein extrem komplexer Vorgang. Wenn man sich überlegt, was man alles verstanden haben muss, was man alles einschätzen können muss und was man alles auch mal erlebt haben muss und wie viel Fail man auch durchgemacht haben muss, um wirklich irgendeiner Quelle oder irgendeinem Subsystem zu vertrauen oder zu misstrauen, zu wissen, warum man jetzt bei Facebook dieses am besten vollkommen links liegen lassen sollte, dass andere aber eine vollkommen legitime Informationsquelle sein kann. Dasselbe mit anderen Medien, mit Twitter, deiner E-Mail, SMSen, die du bekommst. Das ist schon etwas, was man auch enorm gelebt haben muss, um überhaupt in der Lage zu sein, das noch einzubauen in das eigene Leben. Deswegen meinte ich halt auch, da ist dann vielleicht auch die Erwartungshaltung an die Eltern. Da kann man nicht so viel formulieren. Da mag es manche Eltern geben, die werden das schaffen, so. Aber die meisten werden es nicht schaffen, weil es einfach erforderlich ist, damit aufzuwachsen. So, wie man auf dem Verkehr aufwachsen muss, um damit klarzukommen.
Sie werden es halt schaffen müssen. Also alles, was die ältere Generation oder vieles, was die ältere Generation heutzutage dann vielleicht doch schon online macht. So ein, zwei Dinge sich angucken, Online-Banking und so weiter. Das haben sie ja nicht. Das ist ja der Unterschied. Ihr Antrieb ist dabei ja nicht dieses spielerische, das technikinteressierte, das wow, das geht jetzt. Und deswegen will ich das unbedingt machen, weil es einfach geht und cool ist und Spaß macht. Sondern da drängt sich ja etwas in das Leben dieser Generation, was sie nicht unbedingt haben wollen, wogegen sie sich meistens auch sträuben und das Ganze dann nur so weit zulassen, wie sie es zulassen müssen. Also dementsprechend schätze ich, dass vielleicht auch, ich weiß nicht, worüber oder wie, aber dass auch diese Diskussionskultur sich eher in das Leben drängen müsste oder irgendwann die Nachteile daran nicht teilzunehmen, so groß werden, dass der Druck einfach steigt.
Aber so war es ja immer schon. Ich meine, früher waren es andere Dinge. Früher war es irgendwie, dass die Kinder auch mal geil sagen dürfen und so. Da kann ich mich auch noch dran erinnern, dass das mal der totale Ehe klar war.
Die Frage ist also, wo können wir das herkriegen, diese neuen Techniken und wie können wir dafür sorgen, dass wirklich die damit kriegen. Bevor ich mit Sven über diese Frage spreche, möchte ich Patrick kurz fragen, der ziemlich lange rumgeeidelt hat jetzt in der Leitung. Du bist dann? Patrick? Bist du fertig?
Ja klar bin ich da. Aber was bin ich dann?
Ja genau, aber das kannst du auch...
Ich höre ja nicht ständig ins Wort fall.
Aber das kannst du ja auch am Radio tun. Dann machen wir noch ein bisschen Platz für alle Leute, die gerne anrufen möchten und ihre Meinung sagen unter 0331 70 97 110 und das in dieser Sendung.
Zwei Sprechstunden.
Heute Chaosradio mit Pabel Mayer und Tim Prittlauf. Und es geht um Technikkultur und Kulturtechnik. Es geht darum, wie uns diese ganze Technik in den letzten 15 Jahren beeinflusst hat, was sich geändert hat und was vielleicht nicht. Zufälligerweise ist das auch die Zeit, die das Chaosradio alt ist. Und die Diskussion hat sich in der letzten halben Stunde gar nicht so sehr um Technik gedreht, sondern eher um die Art und Weise damit umzugehen. Und die Frage, an der wir uns gerade befinden ist, wo kriegt denn jetzt also wirklich jeder den Umgang mit Technik und mit den Themen, die mit in Verbindung stehen, her? Und dazu hat auch Sven angerufen. So, wo kriegen wir jetzt her, unsere Technikkultur?
Ja, im Grunde genommen haben wir niemanden, der uns das beibringt. Wir müssen uns das alle selber beibringen. Und gerade die Leute, die so wie ich jetzt in einem Alter sind, dass wir damit groß geworden sind, oder das auch noch richtig aktiv erleben, indem wir uns dafür interessieren und das auch alles ausprobieren, sind dann dazu verpflichtet, das auch unseren Kindern weiterzugeben. Ich hab zum Beispiel selber einen sechs Jahre alten Sohn, oder der wird sechs, und den lass ich nicht alleine irgendwas hören, sehen oder nachgucken, sondern das mach ich mit ihm zusammen. Und das haben wir ja auch in der Computerdebatte, also in der Killerspiele-Debatte, dass viele Eltern überhaupt nicht wissen, was ihre Kinder da vor dem Computer machen. Da muss man sich einfach auch mal mit beschäftigen.
Und welche Erfahrung hast du dabei gemacht?
Ich hab zum Beispiel in einer Verwandtschaft mal gefragt, was spielen denn eure Kinder für Spiele? Und die wissen es gar nicht, aber sie vertrauen ihnen. Ja, da frag ich mich, wo ist denn da das Vertrauen? Ich kann ja nicht einfach vertrauen, die machen das schon richtig, sondern ich muss mich da selber auch mit beschäftigen. Ich kann nicht sagen, oh, das ist ein Computer, da will ich mich nicht mit beschäftigen, das ist mir zu hoch.
Was hast du für Erfahrungen gemacht, dadurch, dass du das gemeinsam mit deinem Sohn machst? Also was hat sich bei dem gemeinsamen Spielen oder gemeinsamen Surfen, weiß nicht genau, was du meintest, für dich so ergeben?
Naja, zum Beispiel wollte er mal wissen, wie ein Skelett aussieht von einem Menschen. Und da kann ich ja nicht mich dann mit ihm vor den Rechner setzen und ihm erstmal alle Bilder zeigen, die Google da anzeigt, sondern dann gucke ich mir das vorher an und muss ihn da halt ranführen. Ich meine, wir sind ja jetzt alle in der Phase, dass wir das selber noch lernen. Wie gesagt, es fehlt ja jemand, der das uns beibringt. Wenn ich wissen will, wie ich ein Möbelstück zusammenbaue, dann kann ich meinen Vater fragen. Das hat ja schon alles hinter sich. Der weiß, wie das geht, aber der kann mir nicht das Internet beibringen. Diesmal ist die junge Generation dran, der Alten das vorzuleben und das näher zu bringen. Wir sind jetzt gerade noch in so einem...
Was bist du denn für eine Generation?
31 Jahre.
Naja, aber das ist ja sozusagen die sarkastische Physiophie. Wir warten einfach, bis sie das ausgestorben hat. Meinst du wirklich, das klappt?
Nee, überhaupt nicht.
Sondern wir sind jetzt halt dran, denen, der Eltern oder der nicht-technischen Generation das beizubringen. Sonst bringen sie uns ja immer alles bei. Und will uns für Politik interessieren und will uns ein politisches Leitbild vermitteln. Ich meine, jeder wird von seinen Eltern geprägt, so wie sie einen erziehen, die Meinung, die sie über Politik haben. Und das wäre genauso fahrlässig zu sagen, ich interessiere mich nicht für Politik. Genauso muss ich mich auch für die Technik interessieren. Also ich muss das, was viele Politiker ja auch in der Ernährungsdiskussion sagen, was die Lebensmittelkennzeichnung angeht, wir haben ja alles, na wie heißt das jetzt nochmal, mündige Bürger. Die haben wir aber nicht. Und da muss es halt Leute geben, die sich damit beschäftigen und das in der Diskussion auch weitertragen. Das sind die Leute, die es vielleicht nicht unbedingt hören wollen, aber auch nochmal sagen.
Es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten, die Welt zu sehen. Es gibt natürlich viel mehr Möglichkeiten, aber wenn man den Leuten auch Vertrauen entgegenbringt, wird man natürlich manchmal enttäuscht. Aber alles kontrollieren geht halt nun mal nicht und führt auch nirgendwo hin. Und bei der Frage irgendwann muss man halt als Elternteil auch aufhören, zu kontrollieren. Und wenn ich mir überlege, so die Gefahren, die im Internet drohen im Vergleich zu den Dingen, die wir so als Kinder und Jugendliche in der realen Welt draußen getrieben haben, also welchen Gefahren wir da ausgesetzt waren, da muss ich sagen, da habe ich überhaupt nicht die geringste Bange, so wenn sich irgendein Kind im Internet rumtreibt. Ich meine, wir haben uns in Eisenbahntunnels, die befahren waren, rumgetrieben, wir sind auf morschen Dächern herumgeklettert, wir sind in...
Drogen gefressen.
Ja, alles, also einmal komplett. Wenn ich mir überlege und das ins Verhältnis setze, einfach was im Internet passieren kann, dann sag ich einfach, ja...
Es geht mir nicht darum, meine Kinder bis sie hier ausziehen, sag ich mal, dann zu kontrollieren, aber sie ranführen, in den Umgang damit beibringen.
Das ist auf jeden Fall und sicherlich mit sechs Jahren ist auf jeden Fall vernünftig so.
Ich hab gefragt, was hast du für Erfahrungen dabei gemacht? Also wie wird das sozusagen jetzt von deinem Sohn? Also was für ein Echo hat das, dass du das mit ihm gemeinsam machst? Was glaubst du, wie das bei ihm sozusagen wirkt?
Ja, er versteht das noch nicht, warum ich das darf und warum er das noch nicht darf. Genauso versteht er auch nicht, warum er abends um 20 Uhr bei mir kein Fernsehen gucken darf. Und dann muss ich ihm das halt erklären, warum das halt nicht geht.
Und wie erklärst du ihm das?
Na, für einen Sechsjährigen laufen abends im Fernsehen Filme, die er nicht versteht, wo er Angst bekommt.
Ja, aber erklärst du ihm das genauso?
Ja, genauso. Also ich versuche ihm, die Sachen genauso zu erklären, wie sie sind, aber dann halt kindgerecht in dem Alter. So dass er sich verstehen kann. Das eine ist die Sorgfaltspflicht. Ich muss aufpassen, dass mein Kind solange, bis es das nicht selbst einschätzen kann und mich das vernünftig verarbeiten kann, was da gegebenenfalls geht, solange muss ich mein Kind davor beschützen und soweit es geht ihn dabei betreuen. Aber das andere Aspekt ist ja die Bildungspflicht oder den Bildungsauffrag dahinter. Also mein Kind soweit zu bringen oder das Kind soweit zu bringen, dass es irgendwann das selbst auch einschätzen kann und irgendwann am besten auch selbst weiß, was man auf Facebook stellt und was nicht. Und dass das genau das Partiefoto so ein Ding ist. Und bei dem ersten ist ganz klar, das muss bei den Eltern liegen, weil das geht nun mal nicht anders. Die sitzen nun mal im Haushalt. Bei dem zweiten ist es so eine Frage. Also ich glaube nicht, dass man von den Eltern verlangen kann, dass sie den kompletten Weg der Bildungspflicht, was die Medienkompetenz angeht, da selbst machen, weil sie einfach das Zeug nicht dafür mitbringen. Und wir haben da ja so eine Einrichtung, die genau in diesem Fall irgendwie eintreten soll, dass diese Schule, die all das, was die Eltern vielleicht 20 Jahre danach nicht mehr wissen und vermischt werden können, dem Kind halt beibringen. Und hier sehe ich ein riesengroßes Dichizid, weil das Thema Medienkompetenz noch immer also nicht antwortweise behandelt wird. Von zu kurz kommen kann man glaube ich gar nicht leben. Und ich glaube, dass hier ein riesengroßer Teil dieses Defizits begraben liegt. Ja gut, aber da muss man ja auch mal gucken, wo man als erstes ansetzen kann, damit man weiterkommt. Als ich zur Schule ging hatten wir Lehrer, die haben es nicht geschafft, ein Kassettenrekord anzukriegen. Die sollen unseren Kindern jetzt die Medien erklären. Also ich meine, du kannst nicht immer alles auf die Politik abschieben. Das will auch gar keiner, weil die selber damit überhaupt nicht umgehen kann. Sondern du musst dann auch einfach, wenn du ein Kind kriegst, ich meine, da hört ja Spaß auf. Da fängt das wahre Leben an.
Du selber kannst für dich machen, was du willst.
Aber da fängt ja Verantwortung nun mal an. Und dann...
Also ich möchte an dieser Stelle zwei Dinge tun. Das eine ist, mal eine Lanze für die Lehrer berechnen. Ich kenne ja persönlich einen Lehrer, der hat seine Diplomarbeit darüber geschrieben, wie man Computerspiele im Unterricht einsetzt und tut das auch erfolgreich. Und das andere ist, ich würde gerne Christoph noch dazu holen, der etwas zur Technik als Evolutionsfrage sagen möchte. Christoph, wie meinst du das und wie passt das zum Thema?
Na ja, also die Frage ist eigentlich die Folgende. Es gibt ja sozusagen immer so ein bisschen zwei Gruppen. Das eine sind halt die Leute, die sich für ein bestimmtes Thema interessieren.
Das fälle ich mich jetzt mal mit zu und ihr ja sicherlich auch.
Die andere Frage ist aber, was macht sozusagen der Mainstream? Und der Mainstream benutzt ja eine Technologie, sei es jetzt meinetwegen das Internet, sei es Facebook oder sei es früher mal irgendwie das Rad, wenn es das einfachste ist, was er machen kann. So, sprich, wenn jetzt keine Ahnung, ein 12-jähriges Schulkind mit seinen Freunden kommunizieren will, hat es das früher per Telefon gemacht, jetzt ist es aber sowieso ständig am Rechner. Das heißt, da kann es auch mal eben schnell eine Nachricht auf Facebook oder Studiefortzeit beziehungsweise Schülerfortzeit in dem Fall posten. Genau das Gleiche ist, wenn Politiker sich jetzt mit dem iPad in den Bundestag stellen, früher mussten sie halt irgendwie riesig viel Dokumente ausdrucken. Jetzt können sie einfach ihren Handrechner mitnehmen und sich vorne hinstellen und das Skript irgendwie da aus ihrem Rechner rausziehen und noch schnell interaktiv sich Sachen, Informationen aus dem Netz ziehen zum Beispiel.
Ist das möglich, aber ist das Realität?
Na ja, also in der letzten Bundestagsdebatte, die ich gesehen hab, saßen drei Politiker irgendwie mit iPads vorne drin.
Also von daher, ja schon.
Vor allem deshalb jetzt iPads, weil Laptops immer noch nicht erlaubt sind.
Ja, weil das Ding darf keine Tastatur haben, die klappert, darf nicht zum Klappen sein und keine Lüfter haben. Und es gibt nicht viele Geräte, also größere Geräte, die diese Anforderung erfüllen. Aber ja, da tut sich auch ein bisschen. Allerdings in den Parlamenten, so wie ich gehört habe, funktioniert das WLAN trotzdem nicht so gut. Ich glaube, im Bundestag ist es so, dass Mustern vorher angefordert und eingeschaltet werden.
Ja, so funktioniert das nicht ganz so einfach. Eigentlich ist ja der Punkt, wann benutzt Autonormalverbraucher irgendeine Technik? Also meiner Meinung nach, wenn meine Oma sich jetzt vor drei Monaten entschieden hat, E-Mails zu benutzen, obwohl sie mir fünf Jahre vorher oder fünf Jahre lang irgendwie erzählt hat, es ist alles Raumschiff Enterprise, braucht sie nicht, dann tut sie das, weil sie jetzt eine Freundin hat, die in einem relativ weit entfernten Land wohnt, mit der sie jetzt relativ einfach kommunizieren kann, ohne dass sie teure Telefonkosten oder so auf sich nehmen muss. Dann benutzt sie halt einfach einen E-Mail-Client, weil es ist halt das Einfachste in dem Moment.
Und du meinst, das wird sozusagen auch, also nur das wird sich durchsetzen? Das heißt, es geht gar nicht so sehr um die Vermittlung von Kulturkompetenzen oder Technikultur, sondern es wird einfach das passieren, das beste Gerät oder der beste Service, der gebaut wurde?
Ja, schon. Also ich glaube, dass vielleicht in fünf Jahren benutzen dann alle sowas wie, meines Weges, Twitter oder so. Weil es dann wieder der einfachste Weg ist, Nachrichten zu verbreiten. Gut, wir haben dann in fünf Jahren vielleicht wieder was ganz, ganz anderes. Aber so der Mainstream wächst da, glaube ich, ja, wächst da rein. Es dauert halt eine Zeit, bis solche Entwicklungen ja sozusagen in der Kultur im Leben ankommen. Und die Leute, die sozusagen die Pionierarbeit leisten, sind dann schon wieder an einer anderen Baustelle. Der Schmerz muss einfach groß genug werden, es nicht zu benutzen.
Richtig, genau.
Ja, aber der Punkt beim Internet oder überhaupt bei der Technologie momentan ist ja auch, dass die Entwicklung so rasant vorangeht. Werd vor ein paar Jahren noch an Twitter, an Facebook oder ähnliches im Mainstream gedacht, dass sich das alles immer schneller entwickelt und wir ein Problem haben werden, dahinterher zu kommen.
Na das war ja schon immer so. Also es war immer schon, war alles was Neues, war alles schlimm. Und viel zu schnell. Und früher war es sozusagen sowieso langsamer. Also ich erinnere mich in diesen Fällen immer gerne an die Romane, vor denen früher gewarnt wurde, weil die verursachen Haltungsschäden, machen Jugendliche einsam und aggressiv und führen möglicherweise dazu, dass sie andere Leute umbringen.
Es ist einfach alles Teufelszeug. Ich meine, das ist jetzt wirklich nichts Neues, da wiederholt sich die Geschichte. Ich denke, wir drehen uns jetzt auch so in der Diskussion so ein bisschen im Kreis. Mich würde ja mal ein bisschen interessieren.
Wir haben gleich sozusagen, ich wollte gerade das aufgreifen und sagen, an diesem Punkt kommen wir wahrscheinlich nicht mehr weiter, drehen uns selber, also genau wie die Geschichte im Kreis, wir deshalb Marcel, Sven und Christoph vielen Dank sagen und noch einen schönen Abend wünschen. Und wir haben jetzt das andere Extrem, nämlich dabei, jemand der sagt, es geht auch noch ganz ohne Internet. Da bin ich sehr gespannt, wie das wird.
Wir müssen auch noch mal kurz eine kleine Denkpause haben. Nein, um das mal aufzugreifen, was jetzt hier so auch rauskommt. Ein immer wiederkehrender Konflikt aus den letzten 15 Jahren, den wir immer wieder gesehen haben, genau diese Diskussion, wie es sich jetzt auch entfaltet hat, das Neue gegen das Alte und was du schon gesagt hast, wo kommt sie denn so her, diese Medienkompetenz? Ich denke, das war ja auch eigentlich ein Dauerthema von Chaosradio, bzw. auch eigentlich das Thema von Chaosradio ist ja diese Vermittlung für, also Offenheit überhaupt erstmal für diese Themen zu haben, bzw. auch ganz konkret eben umgehen mit diesen Technologien, gefördert dadurch, dass man eben auch erstmal so eine respektlose Haltung gegenüber der Technik hat, was glaube ich gerade beim CCC auch immer sehr deutlich zutage kommt und auch so Grundsatzverständnis ist.
Ist das eigentlich empfehlenswert, die Umgebung der Technik? Also sollte sich das jeder aneignen? Respektlos?
Es ist mir auch aufgefallen, es ist auch zum Teil eine ganz schön typisch deutsche Diskussion, auch wieder dieser Unterschied, so die Amerikaner, neue Technik. Boah, zeig mal, was kann ich damit machen? Den Deutschen, oh, eine neue Technik. Ist das auch sicher? Was kann da passieren?
Welche Gefahren drohen?
Ja, das ist sicher auch so ein Stück weit Mentalität. Ich will nicht sagen, dass das eine und das andere jetzt besser ist. Also wenn man sich dann anguckt, wohin die Amerikaner sich zum Teil vergaloppiert haben, sind das so ein bisschen fast die zwei Extreme einer Medaille. Man wird sich da vielleicht ein bisschen mehr sowas in der Mitte wünschen. Den Amerikanern eher einen etwas vorsichtigeren Umgang mit Technik und Technikkultur. Und bei uns vielleicht manchmal ein bisschen weniger Technikangst. Aber es zeigt sich auch immer ganz gut, wenn das halt, wenn man jetzt auch wieder 15 Jahre Chaosradio und 35 Jahre Chaos, welche Ausstrahlung diese Hacker-Kultur über den Atlantik gehabt hat. Und in beide Richtungen. Also das, denke ich, ist auch ein ganz interessantes Stück Geschichte.
Das stimmt. Also, ich weiß nicht, ob du das so mitbekommen hast, Markus, aber so diese Hacker-Spaces-Entwicklung. Als der Club gegründet wurde vor 30 Jahren, da war auch ein wichtiger oder es gab mehrere wichtige Auslöser, aber so vor allem diese frühe amerikanische Hacker-Kultur spielte natürlich eine ganz entscheidende Rolle. So Magazine wie Tab-Magazin etc. Damit ist Vauland auch immer unterm Arm rumgelaufen und das war auch so Inspiration und das war ja auch geprägt von diesem respektlosen Umgang. Die Phone-Freaks, die einfach gesagt haben, wir müssen kostenlose Telefonate führen, denn wenn wir für unsere Telefonate bezahlen, dann führen wir eine Tax an den Vietnamkrieg ab und das wollen wir nicht. Das war ja auch schon ganz klar Politik und Gesellschaft und Technologie, das war von Anfang an da in einem Topf zusammen. Und das hat eben auch die Gründung des Clubs mit inspiriert und über die Jahre haben wir dann in Amerika auch so diesen merkwürdigen gesellschaftlichen Verfall ja auch alle beobachten dürfen. Der auch so mit Paranoia nach außen, früher sozusagen die Definition des Einwanderungslandes, der Offenheit der ganzen Welt, sozusagen der Schmelztiegel von allem. Und jetzt sind sie irgendwie so vollkommen in ihrem, wir sind jetzt aber, ab jetzt sind wir ja aber Amerika und der Rest ist alles außen und böse und gefährlich und muss verhindert werden und darf nicht mehr einreisen. Jetzt wendet sich das Blatt auch genauso gegen die eigenen Leute. Mit diesen ganzen Kontrollen, die sie da jetzt haben im Flug, da zeigt sich das eben auch ganz plastisch. Und die Hackerkultur hat enorm gelitten. Also die Hacker waren dann lange Zeit doch das Böse und sozusagen die Definition des Cyberkriminellen und nicht. Also der Sprung zum Terroristen war da auch sehr nah. Das ist glaube ich auch so ein Grund, warum das bei uns auch immer auf so giftigen Boden fällt, wenn wieder mal so eine neue Terrorwelle heraufbeschworen wird, weil das haben wir einfach schon viel zu häufig gesehen. Und jetzt gibt es diese lustige Gegenentwicklung, dass in diesem doch sehr liberalen Deutschland der letzten 20, 30 Jahre eben der Club und drum herum ja auch eine Hacker Szene, die jetzt auch nicht nur unter dem Namen CCC zu führen ist, sich entwickelt hat. Und das vor vier Jahren ging das so eine Rückbewegung los in die USA, inspiriert wiederum durch die deutsche Szene. Und jetzt öffnen da überall diese Hacker Spaces.
Du musst mal kurz erklären, ob ich was ist.
Was ein Hacker Spaces ist. Ein Hacker Spaces ist ein Ort, an dem sich Leute treffen, die eben hacken wollen, in unserem Sinne, also die einfach Interesse haben, Technologie zu erforschen, Hands-on Sachen zu bauen, Elektronik zu bauen, auch Software zu machen, was auch immer, Dinge zu basteln, zu bauen, zu schaffen. Oder eben auch, wie das beim Club ja auch immer eine große Rolle spielt, auch so einen gewissenen, offenen Geist zu leben. Sich einfach mit Leuten zu treffen, die einfach offen sind für Dinge, für Neues, neophil sind. Das sind diese Orte. Die finden sich dann an solchen Orten zusammen, kaufen sich gemeinsam Hardware, wo man dann bauen kann und wo man sich gegenseitig Dinge beibringen kann. Es gab eine extreme Explosion dieser Hacker Spaces vor vier Jahren, nachdem so eine kleine Gruppe bei uns beim Camp aufgelaufen war und total breit war und dachte, das brauchen wir jetzt irgendwie auch. Warum gibt es das nicht in den USA? Und jetzt gibt es das überall. Und das wird darum so cool, dass man sich da schon wieder eine Menge zurückholen kann. So, aber jetzt hatten wir ja auch noch einen Anrufer.
Genau, jetzt kommen wir zu Daniel, für den wir auch glaube ich dann die Hacker Spaces brauchen, weil der meint, es geht auch noch ganz ohne Internet. Hallo Daniel.
Ich habe angerufen, weil mir das irgendwie aufgestoßen ist. Oder nicht aufgestoßen, aber ich habe ein bisschen, ist mir ein bisschen quergekommen von dem, was der Anrufer davor sagte. Und zwar, ich mag Generalitäten nicht. Und der meint, man muss jetzt der älteren Generation das beibringen und geht ja gar nicht mehr ohne. Und ich muss sagen, wenn ich mir zum Beispiel meine Großeltern angucke, also ich meine, meine Oma hat jetzt auch einen Computer bekommen von meinem Onkel. Und ich habe ihr auch rudimentär Schreiben beigebracht, weil sie da halt ihre Geschichten aufschreibt, die sie erlebt hat früher, weil sie die gerne vermachen will so. Aber an sich, die hat es halt früher mit der Schreibmaschine geschrieben. Und das Ding ist, also all diese Technik, die ich auch nutze, sehr viel noch und nöcher, ist ja an sich ist es alles Luxus. Also es geht auch ohne. Und ich meine, es gibt ja noch ganz, ganz viele Orte auf dieser Welt, wo es auch noch ohne geht. Und ich meine, es ist ja jetzt nicht so wie zum Beispiel Medizintechnologie oder so, die jetzt wirklich irgendwie das Leben verlängert oder Leben rettet. Sondern es ist einfach, man hat und das macht das Leben leichter und vielleicht auch ein bisschen komplizierter, weil man halt einfach Verantwortung abgibt oder Arbeit abgibt an andere, die dann von anderen gemacht werden, wo dann halt die Verantwortung bei anderen, bei Maschinen oder bei anderen Menschen oder anderen Diensten halt liegt.
Aber du bist online selbst, ja? Also du nutzt das Internet, ok. Also Briggs, jetzt dich, der das Internet benutzt und deine Großmutter, die jetzt das Internet benutzt, sind vielleicht keine so guten Beispiele dafür, dass das...
Nee, nee, meine Großmutter benutzt das Internet nicht. Sie hat bloß einen Computer, an dem sie lediglich Word benutzt. Aber den benutze ich auch sehr selten, weil sie den nicht so richtig auskriegt und ankriegt. Also es ist immer sehr kompliziert.
Das ist ja auch völlig in Ordnung. Ich meine, das ist halt die Kulturtechnik, die sie erlernt hat. Textverarbeitung, das konnten auch viele Leute nicht. Das können auch viele Leute heute nicht. Und ich finde das auch völlig in Ordnung. Ich meine, man muss ja gar nicht alles können. Und es ist auch, glaube ich, so die Zahl der Kulturtechniken, die man dann wirklich beherrscht, die ist auch endlich. Wenn man sich mal anguckt, was an Kulturtechniken auch, sagen wir mal, jetzt dem Aussterben, vom Aussterben bedroht ist, wenn man sich zum Beispiel mal anschaut, wie die Leute heutzutage schreiben, und ich meine nicht tippen, sondern schreiben, mit einem Stift auf einem Black-Papier.
Das Beispiel passt da natürlich sehr schön mit der Großmutter, die jetzt sogar auch zum Computer kann.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie noch in der Lage ist, ihre Handschrift zu verlernen. Vielleicht mag ihr der Computer da eine Hilfe sein, wenn das Schreiben jetzt medizinisch bedingt nicht mehr so geht. Aber ich merke halt auch, dass die Leute heutzutage nicht mehr so sehr viel von Hand schreiben. Und wenn man sich die Klaue von manchen Leuten anschaut, da läuft es mir kalt über den Rücken.
Du kriegst es auch nicht so leicht per E-Mail verschickt, dein handgeschriebenen Zettel.
Die Frage ist zu sagen, muss man das noch können? Also es ist ein großer Verlust. Also man könnte auch sagen, na ja, kann keiner mehr schreiben, ist aber auch egal.
Und kann sein, dass das so ist, ja, durchaus.
Und noch eine andere, also es geht ja nicht um die Frage, jetzt muss oder muss man nicht, also was ist jetzt unnötig so zum Überleben? Aber das wäre vielleicht noch eine Frage. So brauchen wir das Internet im Moment zum Überleben. Sieht zunehmend danach aus, dass das ernste Probleme verursachen würde, wenn es das jetzt nicht gäbe. Aber die Frage ist, will man das, will man ohne auskommen?
Also ich muss sagen, so weit wie unsere Gesellschaft ist, meiner Meinung nach, würde es wirklich ernste Probleme geben, wenn das Internet jetzt nicht mehr funktionieren würde, weil wirklich schon sehr viel darauf basiert. Ich will bloß sagen, dass man sich selbst entscheiden kann. Also die Gesellschaft als Ganzes würde meiner Meinung nach durchaus ernste Probleme kriegen. Aber Einzelne können sich durchaus wie auch einzelne Leute in Kommunen leben können oder einzelne Leute halt nicht Auto fahren können. Das sind jetzt mehr die Leute, die nicht Auto fahren. Aber wie einzelne Leute einzelne Sachen nicht machen, können sie auch sagen, ich will jetzt hier kein Internet haben.
Das ist ja unbenommen. Aber das sind ja dann die Einsiedler, die Außenseiter. Als Kulturtechnik, als Allgemein ist es schon nötig, oder nicht?
Also ich, nee, Außenseiter, ich weiß nicht. Ich will das nicht so für Allgemein. Ich habe auch meine Eigenheiten oder zum Beispiel habe ich auch kein Handy. Mag ich nicht. Ich bin noch ohne aufgewachsen und das hat noch funktioniert. Es funktioniert immer noch so. Ist auch eine Kostenfrage bei mir. Aber ich weiß nicht, ich fühle mich da nicht als Außenseiter und ich kann trotzdem mit meinen Freunden Probleme mitreden.
Würdest du denn lieber früher leben in einer Zeit, wo es das noch nicht gab und wo du nicht darauf verzichten musstest? Also stört dich irgendwas so an der modernen Technik?
Ob mich jetzt so was an der modernen Technik stört, ist ein bisschen schon die Unterkontrollierbarkeit, aber das geht jetzt glaube ich ein bisschen zu weit. Ich würde nicht früher leben, weil ich muss sagen, so sehr ich sage, auf vieles der Technik kann man verzichten. Gerade die medizinische Entwicklung ist das, was wirklich gut ist, auch wenn die Pharmaindustrie da sehr viel forscht, aber das ist das, was ich nicht zurückdrehen würde.
Ich möchte aber dann doch noch kurz nachfragen, auch wenn wir dann gleich wieder in Fritz Info haben, mit der Unkontrollierbarkeit der Technik. Was genau meinst du damit?
Na ja, also ich meine zum Beispiel, da ist die Tatsache, dass die Internetadressen, ich weiß nicht genau den Fachbegriff dafür, aber die Internetadressenverwaltung ja alles in den USA sitzt. Und wir hier aus Europa aus relativ wenig da machen können zum Beispiel.
Ja das, nein das, also so einfach ist die Antwort nicht. Ich glaub die Angst können wir dir nehmen. Also das ist schon...
Ja, aber ich meine...
Es gibt hier und da, sagen wir mal, Machtkonzentrationen, die vielleicht noch mehr im USA-Bereich liegen, als einem das manchmal liebt wäre. Aber es ist mitnichten so, dass das Internet vollständig aus den USA herauskommandiert wird. Die Zeiten sind auch vorbei.
Ja, ja, das weiß ich. Das meinte ich auch nicht. Ich wollte bloß ungefähr... Ich meine, ich hab auch ganz viele Chaos Radio Podcasts erst in letzter Zeit gehört, weil ich es erst vor einem Monat entdeckt habe. Nichtsdestotrotz wollte ich quasi sagen, ihr werdet viel ruhiger schlafen im Chaos Computer Club, wenn die, also wenn das, die ganze Technik wirklich so beherrschbar wäre, oder?
Aber wärs dann auch wieder langweilig?
Wir wissen, dass die nicht in dem Maße beherrschbar ist.
Ich glaube auch, das wäre natürlich langweilig, weil die Unbeherrschbarkeit der Technik, ein anderes Ergebnis ist ja sozusagen nicht nur der Verlust der Beherrschbarkeit, sondern ist halt auch der Umgang mit Kreativität. Also du kannst sie dann zu neuen Ufern treiben. Wenn sie komplett beherrscht und kontrollierbar wäre, dann ginge das ja nicht mehr.
Ja, das weiß ich, aber die Frage ist halt immer...
Also ich verstehe deinen Punkt. Und da ist ja auch, sagen wir mal, so eine Grundskepsis, die da mitschwenkt, die ich gut verstehen kann. Auf der anderen Seite denke ich, was du ein bisschen außer Acht lässt, und das zeigt sich an deinem Medizinbeispiel schon ganz gut so, es gibt schon einige Auswirkungen, die würdest du missen. Der Punkt ist, die gesamte Entwicklung der menschlichen Gesellschaft auf diesem Planeten in den letzten 20 Jahren, vor allem der letzten 10 Jahre, wäre so ohne das Internet nicht im Ansatz so gelaufen. Und der wissenschaftliche Gesamtgewinn geht natürlich auch weit über Medizin hinaus. Das ist wohl etwas, wo man den persönlichen Nutzen am besten verstehen kann, aber so allein, dass diese Welt überhaupt erst mal begreift, was sie eigentlich ist, unsere Position im Universum und sozusagen unser Verhältnis und die Verletzlichkeit dieses Planeten ist, das ist ja mitnichten angekommen, da braucht man nur gleich wieder auf die Nachrichten warten, dann kommt da wahrscheinlich gleich wieder so, na ja, Atomkraftwerke laufen jetzt nochmal 10 Jahre und so weiter. Da sind so viele Leute, die überhaupt nicht auch nur eine Spur Verständnis davon haben, was ja eigentlich ist, da ist noch viel nachzuholen. Ohne Internet wird uns das nicht gelingen, dieses Wissen aufzubauen und zu verbreiten und die Leute von ihrem Aberglauben zu befreien. Der Meinung ist, die Welt wäre 2000 Jahre alt und irgendwann mal ausgenießt worden.
Und es läuft natürlich auch schon längst der Kampf ums Internet. Also der wird auf ganz vielen Ebenen ausgefochten. Der politische Kampf um die Kontrolle der Technik, der Infrastruktur, der Umsätze, der Informationsflüsse. Also das ist schon auch dann zu etwas geworden, wo das Leben tatsächlich stattfindet.
Also Daniel, ich würde sagen, wir halten fest, du darfst gerne ohne Internet, wenn du unbedingt willst. Wir wollen es aber trotzdem behalten und sind der Ansicht, dass es eine gute Idee ist.
Ich meine, wenn man mich vor die Wahl stellen würde, ob ich es zurückdrehen möchte oder nicht, wenn ich könnte, würde ich es nicht machen. Die Frage war ja, ob ich auch ohne Internet leben würde.
Boah, also wegen, weil das Internet weg ist, würde glaube ich keiner Selbstmord begehen hier, aber man hätte, äh, nee, aber Mord.
Selbstmord nicht, aber Mord. Also das Internet würde schon deshalb nicht verschwinden, weil ich sonst stinkteufels wild wär.
Kann ich noch mal kurz dranbleiben und dann in der Dings was sagen?
In der Dings?
In der Info-Sendung.
Das ist schwierig, weil das alles aus dem selben Studio läuft. Aber wir gucken mal, was wir machen können. Ich sag auf jeden Fall trotzdem jetzt schon mal Tschüss und kündige an, dass wir ein Fritz Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr jetzt machen. Und danach geht's noch eine halbe Stunde weiter mit dem Chaosradio. Heute Chaosradio, eine halbe Stunde geht das 15-jährige Jubiläum. Und zu Gast sind Pavel Meier und Tim Prittler. Hallo und guten Abend nochmal. Ich habe gerade einen Pfaden verloren. Kannst du dir mal kurz erklären, worüber wir den letzten 1, 5 Stunden geredet haben?
Mir viel gerade noch. Das erklärt Tim gleich immer mehr. Da wir die Möglichkeit haben, hier die Nachrichten zu kommentieren, wie es sonst nur im Internet geht. Das zeitliche Zusammenfallen natürlich mit den Haushaltsverhandlungen von dem ganzen Terrorwahn, das ist natürlich jetzt ganz unglücklich, dass das passiert. Da muss man ja jetzt wieder viel Geld ausgeben. Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass es auch Zufall ist. Also ich habe da nicht wirklich irgendwelche Einblicke, aber praktisch ist es natürlich schon, dass das Ganze gerade zusammenfällt.
Ja, ich fand es auch bemerkenswert, dass da gleich so eine Innenministerkonferenz zwei Tage danach stattfand, nachdem so die ersten Warnungen aufkamen. Solche Zufälle, ja.
Und auch schön, keine Gefahr, bitte weitergehen. Es ist eigentlich keine Gefahr. Gerade die Menschen müssen zusammenhalten, ist auch ein schöner Appell, jetzt die Berliner zusammenzuhalten.
Total. Also ich würde in dem Zusammenhang nochmal auf wirhabenkeineangst.de verweisen. Eine schöne Initiative von Mario Sixtus, wo sich Leute zusammenfinden, die irgendwie schnallen, was abgeht. Naja, aber eigentlich werden wir gar nicht über Terror reden.
Aber das führt mich gerade zu einem Thema, die schnallen, was abgeht. Weil, was ich ja finde, ist, manchmal hat mir der Eindruck, das Internet und die ganze Verbreitung von Informationen hat nicht dazu geführt, dass sich jetzt jeder eine eigene Meinung bildet, sondern dass es jetzt noch mehr Leute gibt, die glauben, sie wüssten, was abgeht. Noch mehr als? Früher war es so, es gab halt die klassischen Medien, und darüber die Politiker quasi, in der Informationsherarchie, und die wussten, was abgeht. Und jetzt gibt es sozusagen, jeder informiert sich im Netz, er hat drei verschiedenen Quellen, und er weiß dann auch, was abgeht.
Ich meine, mit diesem früher, das ist ja alles relativ. Kommt drauf an, was für ein früher du jetzt meinst. Ich könnte ja jetzt auch mal ganz böse sein, und früher, als das Radio erfunden wurde, da hingen sie irgendwie alle vor ihrem Volksempfänger, und da wurde da irgendwie reingegöbbelt, mit, ja, vorwärts immer, rückwärts nimmer, und der Feind steht vor der Tür, und wir müssen jetzt alle, unsere Söhne und Töchter, irgendwie in den Krieg schmeißen. Und es gab einfach keine Möglichkeit, irgendwie irgendeine Gegenkommunikation aufzumachen.
Ja genau, aber das war der streichgenaue Punkt, den ich machen wollte. Nämlich, es gab früher sozusagen diese eine Öffentlichkeitsmeinung, die wurde sozusagen eingetrichtert, aufgrund dessen, dass es halt wenige Quellen gab. Heute gibt es mehr Quellen. Das führt aber nicht dazu, dass es zu einer großen Konsenswahrheit kommt, die alle miteinander reden können. Sondern es kommt nur dazu, dass viel mehr Leute glauben, sie sind jetzt informiert und haben die eine Wahrheit rausgefunden.
Es gibt halt jetzt auch für die alternativen Wahrheiten, gibt es auch Kommunikationsforen, die es so vorher nicht gab. Aber das gilt natürlich auch noch für die unterdrückende Macht, meine Meinung, die es eben auch schon vorher gab. Und alle kämpfen da mit denselben Bandagen. Das ist klar, so ist das nun mal. Also nur, weil das Internet da ist, ist noch nicht alles besser geworden. Aber ich denke, ohne das Internet gibt es wenig Potenzial, dass es sich verbessern kann. Und das ist halt einfach jetzt ein gesellschaftlicher Konflikt, der ausgetragen werden muss.
Ja, also die Spielregeln haben sich sicherlich ein Stück weit verändert, was so Informationskontrolle angeht. Wobei es gab halt früher eben eine größere Vielfalt an Zeitungen. Aber tatsächlich die Bandbreite hat zugenommen, die Kommunikationsmöglichkeiten haben zugenommen und die Möglichkeiten, das Ganze zu kontrollieren und zu kanalisieren, haben abgenommen. Aber sie sind halt nicht komplett weg. Es gibt auch im Internet natürlich die großen Meinungs-Schleudern.
Deswegen sind wir ja wieder beim Thema. Deswegen denke ich, ist es sehr wichtig, zu betonen, Technikkultur, das ist etwas, was es schon immer gab. Das ist jetzt nichts Neues, würde ich sagen. Aber es gibt schon diese spezifische, elektronische, netzartige Technikkultur der letzten 20 Jahre, die sich eben mit dem Computer gebildet hat. Die einfach noch mal eine andere, also eine Computertechnikkultur, könnte man auch sagen, die sich jetzt herausgebildet hat, in der sich eben Kunst entwickelt, Meinungen entwickeln, im allgemeinen Sinne Kultur entwickelt. Auch der CCC ist eine Ausprägung dieser Kultur. Es gibt tausende andere Ausprägungen dieser Kultur. Die Apple-Kultur. Aber es geht letztendlich darum, das ist immer so ein ewiger Kreislauf, neue Kulturtechniken zu erwerben. Und dieses allgemeine Umgehen mit dem Netz und diskutieren, was ich ja vorhin schon gesagt habe, das ist womit das Schwerste überhaupt, weil das so eine totale Metakulturtechnik ist. Klar, das ist sozusagen das hohe Ziel, da muss man in kleinen Schritten hinkommen. Aber dazu gehört, dass man sich dem ganzen überhaupt erst mal positiv entgegenstellt und sagt, ja, ich bin auch offen, ich bin neophil, ich will das jetzt wissen und ich will das verstehen und ich will es selber verstehen und ich will es mir selber erarbeiten und ich will selber alles erst mal hinterfragen und ich möchte bitte nicht einfach nur akzeptieren, was mir vorgesetzt wird, weder von meinen Eltern, noch von meinem Lehrer, noch vom Fernseher. Alles Zweifelhafte muss angezweifelt werden. So ein Aufkleber beim Chaos Computer Club Berlin finde ich ganz großartig, der klebt da irgendwie an der Tür und der sagt schon mal eine Menge aus.
Ja, es ist auch tatsächlich, dass im Prinzip alte Konzepte der Aufklärung wieder in Mode kommen mit dem Internet, nämlich für sich selbst zu denken, beziehungsweise, nein, dem Internet in der Hacker-Kultur. Die Hacker-Kultur ist halt auch eigentlich eine Kultur in der Tradition der Aufklärung, weil man dort ja auch versucht, nicht nur Dinge zu machen, sondern dann auch allen anderen mitzuteilen, dass man sie gemacht hat und wie man sie gemacht hat und einfach das Wissen zu mehren und zu verbreiten. Und andere in die Lage zu versetzen, das auch zu tun.
Na ja, es gibt auch die Ansicht von auch, dass gerade Hacker zu so einer Art Elitenabschottung tendieren. Also das schon gerne mitteilen, aber nur den Leuten, die es auch verdient haben, diese Informationen zu erwerben.
Ja, es ist vielleicht aber auch nicht ganz unwichtig, dass da auch eine gewisse soziale Kontrolle auf jeden Fall stattfindet, wobei sie letztendlich nicht wirklich stattfindet.
Ja, machen wir uns nichts vor. Wir sind ja auch ein ganz schön arrogantes Pack manchmal. Da gab es auch genug Chaosradiosendungen, die will man sich eigentlich nicht nochmal anhören. Weil manchmal hat man natürlich auch durch dieses viele Wissen, kommt man schnell in so eine Position der Überheblichkeit, die ist nicht unbedingt immer hilfreich.
Aber meistens.
Aber halt genau beim Kern des Problems angelangt.
Finde ich selbst immer. Für die große Sache müssen wir mal sehen.
Ja, ist schwierig. Ich meine, ich bin so jemand, der dem Wort Elite nicht so viel Negatives abgewinnen kann. Das ist schon so eine gewisse Auslese, das hat natürlich auch jede, das bringt so jede Gruppe auch mit sich. Warum? Wie findet man denn seine Peer Group? Man wählt sich halt die Leute, die dazugehören, wählt man aus. Und es gibt halt Leute, die passen da rein. Und es gibt Leute, die passen da nicht rein. Und man wählt sich eben die Gruppe so, dass man eine Atmosphäre, eine Kultur der Kommunikation erreicht, wie sie einem eben passt. Es gibt Gruppen, die eben eine Kultur der Kommunikation haben wollen, die so ein bisschen minder qualitativ ist. Ja, was weiß ich, so bei Rechtsextremen oder so. Da geht das halt nicht so intelligent zur Sache. Aber in der Hacker-Kultur habe ich halt eine Menge außerordentlich intelligenter Menschen kennengelernt. Die waren nicht unbedingt immer in der Lage, ihre Intelligenz auch in Kommunikation umzusetzen. Die Nerds, die halt wirklich so in so einem Thema drin sind, sind nicht unbedingt immer in der Lage, das zu erklären. Aber das ist eben auch etwas, was man erlernen muss. Und insofern ist, glaube ich, auch Chaosradio für uns so ein bisschen Therapie geworden. Ja, ganz ehrlich. Um einfach das dann auch hinzubekommen, dass man dieses ganze Wissen und diese ganze Verantwortung, die man dann auch damit immer verbindet, das ist ja auch so ein starkes Moment im Club, dass man das auch kanalisiert bekommt. Das gelingt natürlich nicht immer, aber probieren muss man es.
Eine Gegenkultur, um das nochmal, also eine Gegenkultur zur Hacker-Kultur ist so die Marketing-Kultur. Die Marketing-Droiden sind sicherlich, das sind so die Gebrauchtwagenhändler unter den Informationsmaklern. Die versuchen einem mit jedem Trick, einem nicht tatsächlich die Wahrheit aufzuschätzen, sondern zu versuchen, einen zu manipulieren. Ich glaube, dass das ein wichtiges kulturelles Mittel jetzt auch ist, sich zu immunisieren gegen solche Informationsmanipulatoren. Das war glaube ich auch immer wieder so ein wichtiges Anliegen. Deswegen gegen Produkte, also Produkte immer wieder zu enttarnen oder bestimmte Dinge, die die Politik verspricht, die sie nicht halten kann, zu enttarnen, zu entblößen. Das denke ich ist auch ein wichtiger Moment.
Ich würde jetzt gerne noch den Jan reinnehmen. Jan ist 20, kommt aus Duisburg. Und ich weiß gar nicht, ist dir das alles zu komplex oder noch nicht komplex genug mit der Technik?
Ja, also wie soll ich sagen?
Na ja, erstmal, erstmal fang ich glaube ich, ich hab mir schon eine ganze Menge überlegt, was ich noch sagen wollte. Aber ich fang jetzt vielleicht mal direkt an bei dem Anrufer von vorhin. Und zwar hat er gesagt, es geht auch ohne. Und ja, ich glaube es muss manchmal auch ohne Internet gehen. Und zwar ist es so, Internet hat ja eine Menge so Möglichkeiten und Computer und Technik überhaupt. Aber wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel so in den Tante Emma Schuhladen komme, so von nebenan, was mir neulich passiert ist und die mir sagen, sie können mir heute so überhaupt keine Schuhe mehr verkaufen, weil bei denen ein Virus im System ist und die haben da vielleicht so, ich sag mal 100 Paar Schuhe stehen. Und sie können mir halt keinen Schuh verkaufen, weil da halt Virus im System. Dann frag ich mich, wofür muss die Technik da so unbedingt eingesetzt werden? Ich finde es auf jeden Fall gut, dass wir so Leute haben, wie jetzt im CCC, die sich dann halt mit der Technik beschäftigen. Aber die Frage ist dann halt, muss die Technik, nur weil sie da ist, auch überall eingesetzt werden? Und ich glaube, das muss halt nicht. Und ich glaube, da muss man auch so ein bestimmtes Mittelmaß finden.
Auf jeden Fall. Ich meine, das haben wir ja, brauchen wir nur das Thema Wahlcomputer aufzugreifen, was ja auch gerne so als naja, wir müssen ja modern sein. Wir brauchen jetzt Computer und wählen ohne Computer geht ja gar nicht. Da hat der Club ja auch ganz klar positionbezogen und gesagt, das geht gar nicht.
Ja, und da ist so die Geschichte mit der Komplexität. Also ich glaube auch so von wegen so Technikkultur und Kulturtechnik. Ich meine, das gab es alles auch irgendwie schon mal, auch so mit der Zurverfügungstellung von Informationen. Ich meine, ich glaube nicht, dass das beim Buchdruck damals jetzt wesentlich anders war. Also da war es früher auch, ok, Informationen wurden jetzt mündlich weitergegeben und irgendwann ist mal so eine kleine Elite darauf gekommen und hat gesagt, ok, wir fangen jetzt an, wir bringen das auf Papier und das war am Anfang auch alles ganz teuer und so eine Druckmaschine und Papier konnte sich auch nicht jeder leisten. Und es wurde dann auch komplexer, man braucht irgendwie was weiß ich, eine Bibliothek, wo man das alles lagern konnte. Und jetzt hat man halt so Rechnerinfrastruktur, nur entwickelt sich das halt eben immer weiter und wird immer komplexer. Und die Frage ist halt, in wie weit das Ganze dann noch beherrschbar ist.
Ja, das ist immer die Frage, obwohl ich glaube, dass eher die Entwicklung halt genau in diese Richtung geht, nämlich in diese Beherrschbarkeit. Also das ist glaube ich der große Trend, den wir derzeit erleben.
Ja, oder unsere Technik erwacht dann endgültig zum Leben ist vielleicht schon passiert und die Kontrolle entgleitet uns komplett, beziehungsweise da verselbstständigt sich so ein Konglomerat aus natürlichen und künstlichen Intelligenzen und Informationsverarbeitung und Netzwerken. Aber vielleicht war das sowieso auch schon immer so und vielleicht ist das eh nur eine Illusion mit der ganzen Kontrolle über den Gang der Dinge.
Also was ich jetzt zum Beispiel auch noch so in so einem anderen Punkt öfter mal so ein bisschen jetzt plötzlich negativ betrachtet, also ich meine ich bin quasi damit aufgewachsen. Ich war glaube ich schon so in der Grundschule, habe ich so meinen ersten Computer gehabt und Internet war ich auch relativ früh dabei und was mir jetzt halt aufgefallen ist, so in den letzten Jahren ist halt doch relativ oberflächlich auch geworden, so durch die Informationsgewinnung, so wurde ja jetzt heute Abend auch schon drüber gesprochen.
Was ist oberflächlich geworden?
Ja die Hart und Weise, wie man jetzt Informationen verarbeitet und gewinnt. Twitter reduziert sich plötzlich auf so und so viel Zeichen.
Warte mal, Mann oder Du? Allgemeinerst du das jetzt oder bei dir?
So etwas allgemeiner würde ich das schon sagen. Viele schreiben jetzt nur noch irgendwelche Statusnachrichten und keine Briefe mehr oder so. Einige Zeitungen beziehen jetzt irgendwie so just in time irgendwelche Informationen aus dem Netz komplett ungesichert. Und das ist jetzt so eine gewisse Oberflächlichkeit. Und auch so beim Arbeiten.
Ich merke das jetzt an der Uni immer wieder.
Geht man halt ins Netz, sucht sich die erstbeste Quelle und übernimmt das dann einfach, hinterfragt nicht viel. Und die Frage ist jetzt so, ist Kompetenz überhaupt noch jetzt zukünftig was Neues zu schaffen oder einfach nur zu wissen, wo man das Richtige herbekommt?
Also was mir dazu einfällt, ist der Satz Imminent Death of the Net Predicted. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das schon mal gehört hast, aber das ist irgendwie 30 Jahre alt und das ist sozusagen die Erkenntnis, die Leute, die damals Usenet, das war sozusagen noch vor dem Internet da war, was dann später Newsgroups hieß. Die Diskussionskultur dort wurde allgemein als sich in einem Zustand der Verrohung und Verdummung angesehen und es wurde der unmittelbare Tod des Netzes vorausgesagt. Das hat sich sozusagen zu so einem Mem entwickelt und das höre ich bei dir jetzt auch so ein bisschen raus. Ich glaube, dass man das einfach so nicht sehen braucht, weil man kann viel reden, ohne was zu sagen. Fasse dich kurz kann auch eine Qualität sein. Deswegen, dass Twitter sich auf 140 Zeichen beschränkt, das sagt gar nichts aus. Das kann gut sein, das kann schlecht sein. Im Wesentlichen ist es erstmal vollkommen irrelevant. Also ich glaube nicht, dass das jetzt irgendeine qualitative Aussage ist. Es ist eine quantitative Aussage, aber es ist keine qualitative Aussage.
Ja, das behaupte ich auch eigentlich gar nicht. Ich sage halt nur, man müsste dann wirklich drauf achten und dass es eben nicht abgleitet, dass man eben auch da so eine Art Mittelmaß findet. Also es gibt halt Informationen, auch wenn man sie dann auf 140 Zeichen packen kann, die braucht man halt nicht. Und es gibt halt Informationen, die muss man auf mehr Zeichen packen. Das sollte man auch bitte tun. Und es gibt eben Informationen, die sind für dieses Medium geeignet. Und ja, man sollte sich dann doch auch darauf beschränken, dass man diese Informationen dann da angibt und nicht die Informationen, die nicht in das Medium passen, dann an das Medium anzupassen.
Ich meine, da muss man halt erstmal stolpern, bevor man weiß, wie man läuft.
Aber es werden auch nach wie vor noch Bücher geschrieben und gelesen. Ich glaube, so diese Panik, die Bücher sterben aus, die habe ich jetzt lange nicht mehr gehört. Das war, glaube ich, so im Zusammenhang mit Fernsehen. Da war, glaube ich, keiner liest mehr und Bücher sterben aus.
Naja, mit Detett gab es das schon auch nochmal. Da hat es schon mal ein kleines Revival. Aber das letzte Mal wahrscheinlich ist diese Angst untergegangen, als jemand bemerkt hat, dass man auf diesen E-Readern im prallen Sonnenlicht halt noch so geil lesen kann. Bücher wird es auch noch eine Weile geben. So meine Herren, 10 Minuten vor um ist es. Das heißt, das 15-jährige Jubiläum des Chaosradios nähert sich langsam mit dem Ende. Jan, dir würde ich sozusagen, als der, der uns hier als Erster verlassen muss, das erste Schluss-Pleiluier zuteilen. Was wünschst du dir für die nächsten 15 Jahre vielleicht?
Eigentlich, dass es so weitergeht. Ich finde die Diskussion immer sehr interessant. Eigentlich kann es so weitergehen. Und ich bin gespannt, was noch so alles kommt.
Na gut, das können wir machen. Vielen Dank und schöne Habt ihr noch. Bis denn, tschüss.
Das sagst du einfach so.
15 Jahre.
Mein Gott, sollen wir hier noch als Greise sitzen?
Dann bin ich sehr wütend. Es heißt ja Chaosradio. Vielleicht findet ihr auch innerhalb dieses seltsamen Gefügels, dass sich der Club nennt, eine...
Was?
Entkreisungsstadt.
Passiert schon. Entkreisungen. Das kann man dem Club glaube ich nicht wirklich vorwerfen, dass er so altern würde wie die Volksparteien oder so.
Ich finde, wir sind eigentlich noch ganz jung geblieben irgendwo.
Wir machen uns Gedanken drüber, wenn wir alle zum Club treffen, in Anzug erscheinen müssen. Und hier offizielle Farben schliebt. Gibt es eigentlich offizielle Farben vom TTC?
Man hat sich ja noch nicht mal auf ein Logo einigen können.
Okay, also das Chaosradio wird vielleicht nicht die nächsten 50 Jahre, aber ich sage mal, auf absehbare Zeit irgendwie so weitergehen.
Ja, also solange ihr noch diese UKW-Frequenz habt, kommen wir auch noch regelmäßig rum. Aber wenn sie euch die mal abdrehen, dann...
Ja, das mit dem UKW ist natürlich so eine Sache, ne?
Also Entschuldigung, der MP3, für wen haben wir den denn geholt? Also bitte. Er sagt gerade hier, wenn UKW weg, dann kein Chaosradio mehr.
Dann müssen wir nicht jedes Mal hier so weit nach Potsdam rausfahren.
Da wird auch keiner dieses teure Studio mehr heizen.
Eigentlich hättet ihr heute in den zwei Stunden auch die Möglichkeit gehabt, mal ordentlich abzumeckern über das Chaosradio. Das habt ihr irgendwie nicht so wahrgenommen. Vielleicht gibt es auch einfach nichts zu meckern, was ich wiederum nicht glauben kann, wenn man ab und zu mal die Kommentare auf Twitter oder im Chat liest. Aber es gibt auch noch die Seite zur Sendung, wo man das zum Beispiel im Blog machen kann, wo der Podcast in dieser wunderbaren Sendung auch demnächst erscheinen wird. Aber zurück zum Thema Kulturtechnik Technik Kultur. Wie sieht es bei euch aus, die nächsten 15 Jahre?
Ach, immer diese Zukunftsfragen.
Jetzt hab ich mich bis hierher zurückgehalten. Ich hab so noch drei Minuten.
Ich hätte jetzt nett sein müssen, ne?
Nee.
Ich find ja immer die Gegenwart viel interessanter als die Zukunft.
Was ist denn mit der Gegenwart? Hat sich für dich heute noch was geändert? An deiner Sicht auf die Gegenwart?
Heute im Sinne, im Rahmen dieser Sendung? Genau. Was ich gut finde, was ich immer wieder gerne höre, ist natürlich, dass, so wie gerade auch der erste Anruf war, also auch das, was wir hier versucht haben zu entwickeln, auch so verstanden wird, das finde ich toll. Das begeistert mich wirklich. Hätte ich nicht so erwartet, glaube ich, als wir damit angefangen hatten. Aber das lag auch daran, glaube ich, dass wir eigentlich gar keine Erwartungen hatten. Trotzdem finde ich das extrem stark. Und ich habe gemerkt, dass es sinnvoll ist, auch selber sich so einer Diskussion zu stellen. Und viele, die in dieser ganzen Diskussion drin sind und dieser Problematik so, oh ja, ich habe so ein bisschen geschneit, wie der Hase läuft, wie die Welt tickt, aber alle meine Freunde vergammeln auf Facebook und tauschen sich über Fernsehserien aus. Ich kenne diesen Frust, der ist schlimm. Und ich denke, dass man darüber auf jeden Fall nicht verzweifeln sollte und dass es ohnehin sehr viel sinnvoller ist, sich eben den Leuten zuzuwenden, die diese Bereitschaft zum Verständnis bereits entwickelt haben und dass man da mit den Leuten ansetzt, die eben auch schon erste Schritte zeigen, aus der Matrix aufzuwachen, wo hinten der Stecker schon so ein bisschen wackelt. Da muss man ansetzen. Und da muss man sich auch drauf konzentrieren. Das hat überhaupt keinen Sinn. Die ganze Zeit in so Oh Gott, das ist alles so furchtbar und so schlimm und alle sind so doof und Idiocracy und die Dummen werden siegen. Ich glaube das überhaupt nicht. Ich glaube, dass der generelle Trend eher für die Aufklärung spricht. Da braucht man sich nur die Menschheitsgeschichte anzuschauen. Ich meine, wir hatten auch mal ganz andere Zeiten auf diesem Planeten und das ist alles noch gar nicht so lange her. Die ganze Menschheit der Homo Sapiens, da sind gerade mal 40.000 Generationen. Die Wechsel werden von Generationen immer schneller, sodass man eben einfach aufbrechen sollte und offen kommuniziert und thematisiert. Und das bewirkt eben auch was.
Das Internet ist auf jeden Fall eine gute Ergänzung zum echten Leben und nicht so ein Ersatz für echtes Leben, wie das Fernsehen manchmal der Fall ist. Und ich hoffe, dass es nicht zu einem Ersatz wird in den nächsten 15 Jahren. Also es wird natürlich, gehe ich mal von aus, schneller werden, das Internet. Es wird mehr mobiles Internet geben. Wahrscheinlich werde ich noch mehr Rechner mit mir rumschleppen, als ich das jetzt tue in allen Größen. Oder in verschiedenen Formaten.
Was ihr dazu wissen müsst, ist, dass Pavel seit geraumer Zeit mit einem Smartphone, einem Tablet-Rechner und einem Notebook mit mir direkt gegenüber sitzt.
Ja und ein Ersatztelefon habe ich natürlich noch in der Tasche mit anderen Betriebssystemen.
Meine Hoffnung wäre ja, ich brauche demnächst nur noch ein Gerät.
Der Trend geht zum 5. Computer.
Ja, wird nicht passieren.
Okay, mit dieser Voraussicht beschließen wir die heutige Sendung. Vielen Dank, dass ihr vorbeigekommen seid und es einen kleinen Ausblick in Kultur, Technik und Technik Kultur gegeben hat. Nach diesem Chaosradio, dass ihr demnächst als Podcast auch euch einfach von der Seite ziehen könnt, gibt es den Night Flight mit Florian Heiler. Und der wird euch sozusagen, falls euch die Ohren jetzt ein bisschen zugequast sind, die wieder frei blasen mit ordentlich Punkmusik. Und vorher gibt es natürlich noch den traditionellen Abschlusssong von Trackey Birthday und DRAG an Espen Sheet Website. Herzlich willkommen zum Night Flight auf Fritz.
Freitagmorgen 0 Uhr.
Liebe Nerds und Nahelesen, weg vom Computer, rauf auf die Tanzfläche, mal mit den Mädchen sprechen.